l'état monsieur guillaume garot merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre de la santé hier vous étiez en
mayenne pour rencontrer les soignants
les bénévoles les élus engagée dans le
dépistage à grande échelle de la
population dépistage indispensable si
nous voulons casser les chaînes de
contamination de l'aco vide
deux questions se posent aujourd'hui
alors que partout en france se
manifestent des signes d'une reprise de
l'épidémie
d'abord sur les tests
quels moyens humains sont mis en oeuvre
pour permettre des tests massif alors
que les délais d'attentes pour les
prélèvements comme pour les résultats
peuvent parfois être très long et alors
que les équipes mobilisées nous disent
parfois être très fatigué ensuite
question sur les masques ils sont
devenus obligatoires dans les lieux qui
reçoivent du public
très bien même si chacun le sait ici
vous avez vous n'avez cessé de nous dire
pendant des semaines que ce masque
n'était pas utile chacun aura compris en
fait qu' on en avait pas suffisamment
alors la question qui se pose est celle
de la charge de la charge pour les
familles dès lors qu'ils sont
obligatoires pour une famille de quatre
personnes
c'est une dépense de plus de 200 euros
par mois pour les masques chirurgicaux
et de près de 100 euros pour les masques
lavables alors avec mon groupe nous
plaidons depuis des semaines pour la
gratuité de ces masques c'est à dire
leur prise en charge par la puissance
publique au nom de la santé publique à 6
des français ne peuvent porter des
masses pour des raisons financières
c'est notre protection à tous qui sera
altérée c'est donc moi un coup qu'un
investissement pour la santé de tous et
de chacun pour sortir au plus vite de
cette épidémie qui n'en finit pas
monsieur le ministre le port du masque
ne doit pas dépendre du pouvoir d'achat
de chacun mais quand allez vous
permettre de sa gratuité
la parole à monsieur olivier véran
ministre des solidarités et de la santé
monsieur monsieur ministre guillaume
garot vous m'interrogez d'abord sur la
situation épidémique en mayenne où
j'étais avec vous hier après midi pour
constater sur place les efforts
considérables qui ont été mis très tôt
en oeuvre dans ce beau département pour
faire face à une résurgence de
l'épidémie
nous avons ensemble visiter des
structures de test une structure
notamment à l'huisserie qui est capable
d'accueillir 550 personnes par jour
également des drive des trucks l'avons
visité l'hôpital et vous avez pu
constater comme moi la mobilisation de
l'ensemble des agents sur le territoire
mayennais de manière à pouvoir tester
massivement et je veux ici saluer la
protection civile les pompiers les
agents des agences régionales de santé
les agents de l'assurance maladie la
réserve sanitaire infirmiers aides
soignants médecins
je peux tout faits cités mais vous avez
constaté avec moi monsieur le député que
tous étaient à pied d'oeuvre
jour après jour nuit après nuit sans
relâche pour permettre de faire en sorte
que à un maximum de personnes soient
testés vous connaissez les conséquences
sur la courbe épidémique
il y avait encore il ya quelques jours
plus de 8% de tests qui étaient positifs
en mayenne ce qui avait sonné l alerte
hier nous étions tombés à 3 % de tests
positifs ce qui atteste que cette
politique volontariste est en train de
porter ses fruits
j'espère sincèrement avec j'espère
sincèrement avec vous monsieur le député
que bientôt nous enregistrerons
également à des résultats positifs sur
le taux d'incidence mais évidemment
l'application des gestes barrières
s'impose à tous les habitants ce
département comme d'ailleurs pour toute
la population française
sur la question des masques monsieur le
député je voulais vous dire que l'état
ato distribué 5 millions de masques et
gratuit par semaine via les css par les
communes que nous allons réenclencher
cette distribution de masques gratuits à
destination du public précaire notamment
le public qui bénéficient de la
complémentaire santé solidaire et que
par ailleurs deux millions de français
ceux qui sont porteurs de fragilité
peuvent se faire rembourser des masques
chirurgicaux sur prescription en
pharmacie des masques
nous en avons en quantité mais vous
savez monsieur le ministre
la parole est à monsieur jean paul lecoq
avec ou sans
monsieur le ministre des affaires
étrangères certes vous pourriez dire il
ya un an jamais n'aurait pu se dérouler
ainsi jamais l'allemagne n'aurait lâché
sur le principe d'un endettement commun
et on aurait pu s'en satisfaire points
après des négociations marathon
emmanuel macron a dit ce matin que le
jour et est historique pour l'union
européenne
en effet il l'est mais pas pour les
bonnes raisons
les frigos pays bas danemark autriche et
suède ont définitivement pris le pouvoir
et ont imposé toutes leurs conditions et
leur vision d'une solidarité au rabais
baisse du total des subventions de 500
anneaux à 390 milliards d'euros rabais
des cotisations de ces pays sur le
budget européen et conditionnalité des
aides et la conditionnalité des aides on
connaît du club de paris au fmi on sait
ce que ça signifie l'austérité de force
l'ouverture forcée des services publics
aux marchés et la concurrence fiscale et
sociale entre les états la souveraineté
des états membres de l'union européenne
sera encore mise à mal pour permettre
aux obsédés du budget de s'immiscer
partout aux dépens comme toujours des
peuples après la crise de la zone euro
le massacre de la grèce par la troïka et
le break site l'union européenne peine à
être ambitieuse devons-nous vous
rappeler que face aux 390 milliards du
plan de l'union européenne
le plan de relance américain et de plus
de 2000 milliards de dollars sans
compter les états fédérés devons-nous
vous rappeler que pour valider ce plan
la commission a dû accepter une
diminution du budget européen sur la
politique agricole commune sur les aides
à la transition écologique et sur le
budget de la santé
une honte au regard des attentes des
citoyens européens
ce plan organise des solidarités
capitaliste contre les peuples
les députés communistes vous demande
pourquoi vous avez accepté de sacrifier
la démocratie les droits humains tout en
soutenant les paradis fiscaux sur
l'autel des profs du profit comme souci
or comme toujours dans cette europe
libérale l'argent vaut plus que les gens
merci chers collègues la parole est à
monsieur jean yves le drian ministre de
l'europe et des affaires étrangères
monsieur monsieur le député lecoq
c'est un accord historique
que vous le vouliez ou non
l'historique car l'europe n'a pas raté
son rendez vous avec elle-même
historique parce qu'il permet à l'union
de se doter d'un fonds de relance massif
de 750 milliards d'euros pour répondre
et à la crise du coc vite 19 et pour
permettre de relancer l'économie
historique monsieur le député legault
cas pour la première fois dans son
histoire le principe d'un endettement
commun est acté et comme vous le savez
pas ce que vous avez fait référence à
d'autres moments de l'histoire il y
avait eu des tentatives de fait y
compris au moment de la crise grecque y
compris au nom de la crise de 2002 2008
et aujourd'hui c'est au rendez-vous
réussir cet engagement d'un endettement
commun est remarquable et marque un
tournant
mesdames et messieurs les députés dans
la construction européenne je voudrais
vous dire aussi que contrairement à ce
que vous dites
grâce à la manière dont ce fonds de
relance va être mise en place et en
particulier grâce aux 390 milliards
d'euros de subventions c'est un
mécanisme de solidarité et se font là
permettra d'aider les régions et les
pays qui sont le plus en difficulté il
était normal
td l'italie et de l'espagne qui ont été
les premiers touchés par la crise et qui
nous ont permis de tirer les leçons et
d'être plus épargné par cette pandémie
et donc l'europe est aussi monsieur le
député au rendez vous de la solidarité à
la france était confiante mais si ce
résultat a pu être atteint vous l'avez
dit en commençant dommage que vous
n'ayez pas poursuivis c'est parce que
entre la france et l'allemagne
il y avait une entente incontournable
elle est indispensable pour rassembler
autour de ces deux pays les forces
nécessaires pour faire avancer l'europe
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à madame valérie gomez bassac
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre de l'europe et des affaires
étrangères très cher collègue jacques
delors dont on sait tous en cette
assemblée la contribution cruciale à la
construction européenne fêté hier ses 95
ans et je tiens ce jour historique pour
l'union européenne à lui témoigner ma
reconnaissance au lendemain de la crise
de 2008
il posait la question ces termes les
européens ont le choix entre la survie
et le déclin après quatre jours passés
par le président de la république à
bruxelles pour défendre un accord que
d'aucuns auraient cru possible le
résultat est là au lendemain d'une crise
sanitaire sans pareil les chefs d'état
et de gouvernement européens ont fait le
choix de la survie au fait le choix de
la solidarité ont fait le choix de
l'union plutôt que de la division
certains voudraient nous faire croire
que cet accord n'en est pas un mais où
était-il en 2008 quand il fallait éviter
que l'europe perdent pied les français
ont bonne mémoire
ils savent qu'aucun accord n'avait pu
être trouvé et ils en ont payé un lourd
tribut nous voyons l'avènement d'un jour
nouveau pour la construction européenne
après quatre journée d'âpres
négociations
je salue l'abnégation du président de la
république et votre travail préalable
pour le plan de relance franco allemand
qui a ouvert la voie au plan de relance
européen
alors monsieur le ministre en quoi cet
accord sur un emprunt de 750 milliards
d'euros et sur un budget 2000 74
milliards d'euros sur sept ans permet
aux états membres de faire vivre la
solidarité face à l'adversité et à
l'europe de s'ouvrir dans une nouvelle
dimension qui assurera sa souveraineté
face aux autres puissances qui se serait
délecter de la voir ainsi échoué pouvez
vous en cette assemblée rappeler en quoi
cet accord est historique pour les
français qu'ils soient de carnoules ou
de redon d'illkirch ou de peau je vous
remercie
merci madame la députée la parole à
monsieur jean yves le drian ministre de
l'europe et des affaires étrangères
madame madame la députée comes bassac
vous avez cité jacques delors je parle
souhaité un anniversaire comme vous mais
je pense qu'on peut le faire
il ya 95 ans mais le rappeler surtout
que dans le passé quand il était
président de la commission où il avait
eu usage de répéter que l'europe se
construisait dans les crises et c'est
bien une crise que nous traversons et
c'est bien une étape supplémentaire de
la construction européenne que nous
venons de vivre et je voudrais vous dire
madame comes beau sac puisque j'ai déjà
répondu en partie à votre question en
répondant à monsieur lecoq
en fait il y avait deux négociations en
une puisque à la fois on débattait à 27
sur le plan de relance ces conditions sa
structuration et à la fois en
débattaient du cadre financier
pluriannuel pour sept ans et donc le
sujet de ces quatre jours
c'était un sujet à 1824 milliards
d'euros et je dois dire que sur l'autre
partie de la négociation que l'on oublie
un peu les attentes deux françaises ont
été je pense atteintes par ce que parce
que monsieur lecoq les politiques comme
une traditionnelle que nous soutenons
était non seulement préservé mais
renforcée je pense en particulier à l'
enveloppe globale de la pac
je pense en particulier à la politique
de cohésion et en particulier au fait
que seront préservés dans les sept ans
qui viennent
la place des régions did région
transition qui concerne particulièrement
la france
ensuite ce budget permet aussi
d'investir dans l'avenir pour sept ans
sur j'ai précisé sur la pâte vous n'avez
pas entendu merci de me relire
éventuellement mais par ailleurs ce
budget prévoit d'investir dans des
domaines d'avenir essentiel que son
l'ambition climatique puisqu'il a été
acté que 30 % au moins du budget devrait
y être consacrés et c'était une demande
de
france et puis il ya aussi un engagement
très fort en direction de la jeunesse et
tout cela fait un an semble porteur pour
l'avenir de l'europe est au service des
européennes et d'un érotisme monsieur mu
la parole à monsieur eric coquerel
monsieur le premier le premier ministre
à propos du sommet européen
votre propagande grandiloquente parle de
jour historique
je vous réponds avec réalisme c'est une
faillite tragique pendant que les
dirigeants européens font les marchands
de tapis
nos concitoyens n'ont toujours pas vu le
début de l'ombre de cette soi-disante
europe qui protège la situation est
grave nous français comme d'autres a
vendu arrêté presque tout le pays
nous avons des services publics comme
notre hôpital miné par des années
d'austérité budgétaire voulue par
l'union européenne nous peuples
européens
nous avons besoin d'un grand plan de
relance de notre économie
pas pour bavarder s'auto féliciter dans
un sommet mais pour survivre
le problème c'est que l'union européenne
que vous avez construite n'est pas celle
de la solidarité des peuples l'union
européenne que vous avez construite
c'est celle du libre échange de
l'austérité de la concurrence à tous les
étages comment avez vous pu croire que
le monstre libéral que vous avez nourri
allait subitement se la jouer
coopération aux relances massives pas la
transition écologique et investissements
dans la santé publique
le résultat est là les montants négociés
sont finalement indigent au regard des
deux mille milliards d'euros qu'avait
proposé le parlement européen
votre plan de relance ne relance rien
puisqu'il ne couvre même pas de moitié
les pertes estimées par l'épidémie de
covin 19 vous avez cédé pour un accord
de boutiquier vous avez cédé au chantage
des égoïstes alors que la france en
terre encore ses 30000 morts
l'espagne fait 28 morts l'italie c'est
35 mille morts
pire cela donne à l'union européenne un
nouvel outil de chantage pour imposer
des plans d'austérité à nos pays
pendant ce temps dans vos débats n'a
même pas été envisagé la solution tout
proposions celle qui consistait à
transformer la dette via la bce en
dettes perpétuelles pour l'annuler face
à ce résultat catastrophique du conseil
européen ce qui se joue c'est l'avenir
de l'union européenne
parce qu elle ne survivra pas des
disparités économiques au telle ampleur
plus grave celle à dire d'autres pays
des français je vous le demande donc
donc allez vous enfin investir dans un
plan français pour que notre économie ne
décroche pas et que les financements
soient conditionnées à merci monsieur
jean yves le drian ministre de l'europe
et des affaires étrangères monsieur le
député coquerel où en étions-nous au
début des négociations de bruxelles
certains pays voulaient une relance
minimum ne voulait pas d'emprunts
communs ne voulait pas de subvention ne
voulait pas de transfert ne voulait pas
de redistribution voulait en plus se
mettre un veto sur les plans de relance
des différents états ne voulait pas
entendre parler de ressources propres
où en sommes-nous après il y a un plan
de relance de 750 milliards d'euros
il y à 390 milliards d'euros de
subventions il y a le principe d'un
emprunt collectif jamais arrivé il y à
une distribution majoritaire de
subventions pour les régions les pays
les plus pauvres
je m'étonne que vous ne relevez pas il y
à là le refus du veto de tel ou tel état
sur les autres pour la validation des
plans de relance il y à l'affirmation du
principe des ressources propres et vous
vous appelez ça un échec
j'appelle ça une avancée historique
bien
tu peux bugs
la parole est à monsieur le président
patrick mignola et à lui seul
merci monsieur le président sur le
premier ministre et est cher collègue
oui monsieur le ministre des affaires
étrangères cette nuit l'idée européenne
aurait pu s'éteindre
mais grâce à l'intervention grâce à
l'impulsion de l'allemagne et de la
france
les dirigeants européens se sont
ressaisis ils ont trouvé les voies d'un
accord d'un compromis
ils ont enfin réalisé que né sur l'idée
de paix de prospérité
l'europe devait se prolonger sur l'idée
de solidarité et pour la première fois
ils ont décidé d'emprunter ensemble pour
investir ensemble je crois que les
françaises et les français ont bien fait
en 2010 est de choisir un président de
la république et croyait tant l'europe
car c'est seulement quand on croit en
l'europe on peut convaincre les
européens
un président de la république qui
croyaient au fond que l'europe ne sert
pas qu'à réglementé l'économie mais à
protéger nos valeurs et nos vies mais
devant nous
devant nous d'autres questions vont se
faire jour dans l'histoire européenne il
y aura le green deal il y aura les
infrastructures de transport il y aura
le contrôle aux frontières en matière
sanitaire ou en matière migratoire
il y aura là juste taxation des gars fin
il y aura l'invention concrète de
nouveaux accords commerciaux
internationaux
enfin qualifié sur le plan écologique et
sur le plan social alors nous devons le
dire devant la représentation nationale
toutes ces questions ne pourront pas
être tranché par des compromis et donc
comme le rappelle régulièrement notre
collègue jean louis bourlanges et comme
il l'a fait hier encore quelques
semaines
nous devons proposer au moment où
l'allemagne puis la france vont
président l'union européenne de
nouvelles de nouveaux types de prise de
décision en europe
l'europe doit être plus démocratique et
la démocratie ce n'est pas toujours
l'unanimité au contraire l'unanimité
c'est parfois la tyrannie des minorités
l'europe l'europe ça doit être une
démocratie où la majorité et
éventuellement une majorité qualifiée
s'exprime monsieur le premier ministre
quelles seront les propositions de la
france quand elle présidera l'union
européenne pour que après avoir décidé
d'emprunter ensemble d'investir ensemble
elles puissent mieux décider ensemble
est prolongée ce qui s'est passé cette
nuit là renaissance européenne
merci monsieur le président la parole
est à monsieur le premier ministre
monsieur monsieur le président monsieur
le présent mignola mesdames et messieurs
les députés comme à chaque fois dans les
temps de crise la france a été au rendez
vous de la construction européenne
elle l'a fait je le rappelle à la
représentation nationale sur les bases
qu avait tracé le général de gaulle et
le chancelier adenauer et c'est une
nouvelle fois l'alliance franco
allemande portée par le président de la
république et la chancelière qui ont été
à l'origine ne vous en déplaise de cet
accord historique de cet accord
historique
j'ai vécu j'ai vécu comme beaucoup ici
la précédente crise de 2008-2010 avère
avec laquelle nous avons eu faire
affaire à des problèmes essentiels et
nous avions alors mobilisé beaucoup
d'énergie mais l'europe ni au plan
budgétaire ni au plan monétaire n'avait
alors été au rendez vous et ils
s'étaient est il sale été suivi après
une période de relance une période
d'austérité particulièrement
préjudiciable à notre pays aux
françaises et aux français
nous savons aujourd'hui qu'il animera
différemment l'accord obtenu à bruxelles
après des négociations acharnées
sans doute les plus longue qu'ait connu
un sommet de cette nature sa compagne je
le rappelle à l'assemblée nationale
d'une évolution profonde depuis le début
de la crise sanitaire
de l'attitude de la banque centrale
européenne évolution à l'origine de
laquelle la france et l'allemagne sont
également ont également été motrices
politique budgétaire nouvelle politique
me politique monétaire nouvelle nous ne
l'avions pas obtenu par le passé dans
cette ampleur
l'europe s'occupe de nous l'europe vient
nous protéger c'est son rôle
c'est son rôle et nous allons et nous
allons monsieur le président continuer
et nous allons continuer nous allons
bénéficier très directement du plan de
relance européen pour notre plan de
relance national à hauteur d'environ 40
milliards d'euros montant inédit est
significatif combien par le passé nous
aurions aimé disposer de la moitié de
cette somme
nous allons peser davantage pour faire
évoluer la politique de la concurrence
européenne sa politique douanière
extérieur une politique fiscale plus
verte
l'émergence de grands champions
européens oui une voie nouvelle s'ouvre
à l'origine de laquelle se trouve la
france et nous allons la poursuivre et
l'amplifier
merci monsieur le premier ministre la
parole est à valable s'il vous plaît la
parole est à mme adam un jeune var et
elle seule merci merci monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le premier ministre c'est au
coeur de l'été en pleine crise
économique que vous avez voulu présenter
en catimini la seconde lecture du texte
bioéthique le 14 juillet pas un ne du
président de la république sur ce sujet
pas un mot non plus monsieur le premier
ministre dans votre déclaration de
politique générale
c'est pourtant un des tout premiers
textes de du gouvernement que vous
dirigez personne ne comprendrait que
vous restiez silencieux sur un texte
aussi fondamentale sauf à vouloir vous
dérobez monsieur le premier ministre
j'attends que vous répondiez vous ne
pouvez pas vous dérobez vous êtes le
chef de la majorité c'est pourquoi je
vous le demande solennellement et ma
question est simple
quel est votre avis votre avis sur ce
texte
merci la parole est à monsieur olivier
ferrand ministre des solidarités et de
la santé attendez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
allez monsieur le ministre monsieur le
ministre monsieur willy attendait cesser
ces enfantillages
je vous signale que le gouvernement
répond par la voix du ministre qu'il
choisit lui même c'est la règle
s'applique en tout temps et à tout le
monde
monsieur le ministre vous avez la parole
et lui seul a la parole
vous p écoutez la réponse s'il vous
plaît je me retourne vous avez la parole
madame madame la députée je n'ai pas
encore dit un mot messieurs les députés
madame la députée annie genevard vous
l'aurez constaté je ne suis pas le
premier ministre je comprends que cela
vous attriste néanmoins sachez que nous
sommes pas un mais trois ministres en
charge de la loi bioéthique avec eric
dupond-moretti pour la justice avec
frédéric vidal pour l'enseignement
supérieur et la recherche
et moi même pour le ministère des
solidarités et de la santé madame la
députée indigènes barre j'ai eu
l'occasion de répondre à la même
question on pardonnerait de votre la
part de votre collègue patrick hetzel il
ya quinze jours vous avez utilisé vous
même la même expression haut parleurs
d'adoption d'un texte en catimini et
j'avais eu l'occasion de répondre à
monsieur le député patrick est telle que
pour un catimini plus d'un an déjà de
travaux législatifs c'était dans doute
très long j'ajoute qu'au préalable il ya
eu les travaux du conseil consultatif
national d'éthique de l'office
parlementaire des choix stratégique et
scientifique que la commission spéciale
à laquelle vous avez participé
activement je le sais madame la députée
a eu l'occasion de se prononcer déjà à
deux reprises que la majorité
sénatoriale ainsi que l'opposition au
sénat a eu l'occasion de se prononcer
une première fois et le ferons une
deuxième fois et que donc cette loi
bioéthique qui porte en elle des
avancées sociales sociétales médical
scientifique est une loi qui est attendu
par une grande partie de la population
française madame la députée au delà des
sujets sociétaux que je le sais oppose
une partie de votre groupe avec une
partie du mien il y à d'autres sujets
encore d'importance majeure pour
l'avancée de la science et de la santé
dans notre pays qui justifie pleinement
que nous puissions adopté ce texte dans
les délais impartis et je me réjouis
d'être avec vous la semaine prochaine
dans cet hémicycle pour adopter cette
belle loi bioéthique jeu le var
chenevard là par un monsieur monsieur le
premier ministre
on aurait aimé vous entendre sur
l'éviction du père dans la conception
d'un enfant au mépris de son intérêt
supérieur
mes chers collègues là je vais citer les
défenseurs de la loi qui ont dit de
cette loi c'est un changement de
civilisation ce n'est pas nous qui le
disons c'est vous on aurait aimé vous
entendre monsieur le premier ministre
sur la réécriture du droit de la
filiation sur les changes deux sites au
sein de couples de femmes qui est une
forme de gpa à laquelle vous prétendez
vous opposez sur le tri des embryons
monsieur le premier ministre sur le tri
des embryons pour dépister le handicap
en contradiction avec l'inclusion que
nous prenons tous sur le mélange
monstrueux des cellules animales et
humaines
transgressant la barrière des espèces
voilà la réalité de cette loi qui
franchit les limites éthiques dont vous
monsieur le premier ministre vous avez
choisi de ne rien dire merci madame la
députée monsieur le ministre vous avez
la parole
[Applaudissements]
22 secondes madame la députée ne seront
jamais suffisantes pour que je vous dise
pardon à la réputée au delà du respect
que j'ai pour vos convictions et vos
travaux pour ce que m'inspire les
motrices pour mot ce que m'inspire les
mots chimères et le doigt que vous
pointez sur franchement sur une loi qui
n'est pas partie de cela elle parle
d'amour elle parle de famille elle parle
de filiation
elle parle de recherche elle parle de
santé c'est cela dont par la loi
bioéthique manama députés faites
attention aux mots comme utilisé
derrière chacun des mots et des tamis
métallique news
bien s'il vous plaît on retrouve ses
esprits et en écoutant silence monsieur
aviez battu qui a la parole nir merci
monsieur le président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur julien normandie ministre de
l'agriculture et de l'alimentation
j'y associe ma collègue cerveau jimson
monsieur le ministre la france est
leader le leader mondial de la
production de lin les agriculteurs
normands en assurent 60 % suivis par
ceux des hauts de france et d'île de
france
dans un contexte de crise sanitaire
inédit
l'asie qui importe 80 % de la production
de nos régions a brutalement annulé
toutes ses commandes au moment même où
la campagne d'arrachage de l'un est
lancée sur nos territoires
l'arrêt des exportations a de lourdes
conséquences sur toute la filière
tout d'abord pour les mici 1500
agriculteurs liniculteurs de france qui
sont aujourd'hui dépendant du marché
mondial du textile
de plus les transformateurs c'est à dire
les tailleurs les baigneurs les
filateurs vont subir de plein fouet
cette crise conjoncturelle qui
pourraient ces prochains mois glisser
vers une crise structurelle fibres
naturelles le l'un des atouts
considérables
elle présente aussi des caractéristiques
qui permettent d'en faire des produits
biosourcés monsieur le ministre
avec plusieurs de mes collègues députés
nous avons rencontré les différents
acteurs de la filière la en france si
l'on apprécié les mesures d'urgence
mises en place par le dans le cadre de
la crise sanitaire
ils attendent aussi des mesures fortes à
court terme la première serait
d'accompagner les premiers acteurs de la
filière du lin pour le financement le
stockage et l'engrangement de la paye ou
de la filasse la seconde est
d'accompagner les organisations
professionnelles à faire la promotion du
lin auprès du grand public pour relancer
la consommation
un moyen terme la filière de tête
accompagnés financièrement dans ses
démarches d'innovation dans les domaines
de la recherche du développement en
particulier pour les pour la fiba
destination technique et ceci pour ne
plus dépendre entièrement de l'asie
enfin les secteurs de l'automobile de
l'aéronautique des énergies
renouvelables ou de l'habillement
bénéficient d'un certain nombre de
mesures d'accompagnement par l'état
c'est bien ce dernier terme donneurs
d'ordre il faut prendre en compte le lin
qui présentent des valeurs ajoutées par
rapport aux fibres faux
cl monsieur le ministre quel plan
d'action est il prévu pour presser fait
observer chez guerlain dynamique et
comment l'intégrer rôle dans le sens
mieux julien de normandie ministre de
l'agriculture et l'alimentation
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés
monsieur le député xavier battu d'abord
d'abord le lin comme toutes les filières
agricoles
aujourd'hui va bénéficier de l'accord
historique signé cette nuit parce que
cet accord historique européen
il permet de préserver de conforter la
politique agricole commune
cet accord il fait que la politique
agricole commune elle sera plus
solidaire elle permettra de financer les
transition écologique
elle permettra de préserver le budget
est cette politique agricole commune
elle est le fruit de l'engagement du
président de la république et de la
france auprès des partenaires européens
pour faire en sorte que la première
proposition de l'année dernière soit
revu considérablement à la hausse et
puis de ces sommet bruxellois je vais
redescendre dans les plaines normande
effectivement dans les plaines normande
ou dans les hautes france aujourd'hui
nous avons un terrible défi qui est
d'accompagner cette filière d'excellence
qui la filière du lin il faut en faire
la promotion elle est encore méconnu je
porte à votre initiative et initiative
de plusieurs parlementaires ce jour une
cravate ont l'un comme témoin fabriqué
en france est produite en france comme
témoin de cette filière d'excellence
il nous faut pousser la promotion il
nous faut pousser les stockages même si
on sait que c'est difficile et il nous
faut aussi monsieur le député inclure
dans le plan de relance la filière lin
comme les autres filières agricoles
voilà les engagements que je prends à
vos côtés que ce soit au niveau
bruxelles a au niveau national c'est
comme ça que nous soutenons soutiendront
ces filières je vous remercie
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à madame brigitte puisse faire
ma question s'adresse à madame la
ministre de la culture à peine plus d'un
an après la sortie de notre dame c'est
la cathédrale de notes qui était en
proie aux flammes
et c'est un nouveau malheur qui frappe
notre patrimoine religieux national je
me réjouis évidemment que les 2 4 et
dral ne soit a priori plus en danger et
je veux saluer ici
l'incroyable courage des centaines de
pompiers qui sont intervenus pour sauver
ces deux édifices face à face aux périls
qui menacent le patrimoine religieux
national il convient de s'interroger sur
les moyens financiers pour assurer la
sécurisation des cathédrales 6,2
millions d'euros ou ayant été affecté en
2020 c'est un premier geste vous le
conviendrait qui malheureusement est
insuffisant en effet le rapport de notre
collègue gilles carez en 2019 pointé que
sur 87 cathédrale dont l'état est
propriétaire
seuls 22 sont en bon état en revanche 47
sont dans un état jugé moyen 15 sont en
mauvais état et deux sont jugés en même
en état de péril partiel ce diagnostic
madame la ministre vous en conviendrez
particulièrement alarmant et cette
situation n'est pas acceptable et elle
ne peut perdurer
vous héritez donc d'une situation
difficile mais l'urgence impose que
l'état en tant que propriétaire de ces
édifices assume ses responsabilités en
tant que nouvelle ministre de la culture
quelles actions comptez vous mener et
quels moyens supplémentaires
entendez vous met au service de la
sécurisation des cathédrales
je vous remercie merci mesdames débuté
la parole à madame roselyne bachelot
ministre de la culture
le président mesdames et messieurs les
députés madame la députée brigitte
kuster
d'abord je voulais vous remercier pour
l'action que vous menez à la tête de la
mission d'information sur notre dame de
paris
remercié aussi votre collègue raphaël
gérard qui a été touché par
vide de passe est très grave et qui
avait assuré ses fonctions de rapporteur
je voulais lui adresser mes voeux de
prompt rétablissement car c'est un homme
particulièrement impliqué sur les
questions du patrimoine effectivement
vous avez salué l'action des forces de
sécurité des pompiers de nantes et
d'ille et vilaine avec le premier
ministre et le ministre de l'intérieur
nous avons eu l'occasion de les
remercier parce que vraiment ils ont
fait un travail remarquable de remercier
aussi les services de la direction
régionale des affaires culturelles qui
ont procédé à au transport des oeuvres
d'art qui était situé dans la cathédrale
alors effectivement grâce à mon collègue
franck riester en charge à ce moment-là
du ministre de la culture a été lancé un
plan de mise en sécurité des cathédrales
la diagnostic a été fait à la cathédrale
de nantes qui n'avait pas relevé de
difficultés considérables en ce domaine
nous allons évidemment continuer ce
diagnostic nous allons continuer des
travaux importants je rappeler par
exemple que sur le plan cathédrale dans
la cathédrale de nantes c'est 15
millions de travaux qui était prévu 15
millions de travaux divers dont en
particulier 1,7 million destiné à l'ami
à la mise en restauration et à
l'entretien de l'orgue qui maintenant
hélas est à terre et nous allons
continuer ce travail je remercie les
d'ailleurs ce qui s'est passé à
bruxelles ce qui s'est passé au sommet
européen
ce sont des sommes considérables et il
n'est pas douteux qu'une partie de ces
sommes considérables seront consacrés à
la culture et à la préservation du
patrimoine
merci mon analyse avant de débuter
madame la ministre avant d'attendre les
subsides de l'europe oicha temps de mon
gouvernement qu'il apporte des réponses
fermes la protection du patrimoine sa
restauration doit être une priorité pour
tous le patrimoine religieux appartient
je viens de le rappeler 87 cathédrale à
l'état
l'état est propriétaire l'état est
responsable merci madame la députée
la parole monsieur michel castellane
merci merci monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse au ministre de
l'économie des finances et aussi je me
rappelle de la relance monsieur le
ministre à notre groupe salue l'accord
trouvé cette nuit au conseil européen
la création d'un plan de relance sur la
base d'un emprunt commun aux 27 est une
avancée indéniable la construction
européenne même si l'enthousiasmé doit
être tempérée sur les rabais accordés à
certains pays ou sur les concessions sur
le cadre budgétaire 2021 27
cet accord est un tournant il doit
désormais être décliné dans chaque pays
membre
dès le 3 juin l'allemagne dévoilé un
plan de relance de 130 milliards d'euros
sur deux ans assommés dernière le
premier ministre a esquissé un plan de
100 milliards
si nous avons bien compris quarante pour
cent de ce montant sera donc financé par
l'europe et le plan européen ne s'agira
pas au plan français selon avons bien
compris toujours le plan français sera
dévoilé en conseil des ministres le 24
août et un cercle dans le budget pour
il ya là un hiatus regrettable nous
avons dit la nécessité de nous projeter
rapidement dans la violence car la vague
de défaillances d entreprises menacent
gravement
quand % des plans européens sera
consacrée à la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique contre
seulement 20% au plan français allez
vous monsieur le ministre corriger cette
répartition
nous rejettons d'ailleurs que la corde
sur le 3e budget rectificatif s'est fait
sauter les avancées pour accélérer la
rénovation énergétique des habitations
j'en viens à ma question dans la
déclinaison de ce plan de relance est
nous semble indispensable d'associer
sans attendre le parlement et les
collectivités notamment l'échelon
régional
aussi monsieur le ministre nous faisons
une offre organiser la consultation du
parlement et des territoires
même s'il nous faudra travailler l'été
le président avait d'union nationale
vous avez là l'occasion de la mettre en
oeuvre
y êtes-vous prêts monsieur le ministre
la parole merci cercles avec la parole
est à monsieur bruno le maire -ministre
de l'économie et des finances le
président mesdames et messieurs les
députés monsieur le député et castellani
oui l'accord qui a été trouvé cette nuit
est un immense succès un succès pour le
président de la république pour cette
majorité pour la france un succès pour
le couple franco allemand est un succès
pour l'europe toute entière pour la
france et 40 milliards d'euros qui vont
être immédiatement disponibles pour
financer le plan de relance de 100
milliards d'euros que je présenterai la
demande du premier ministre et du
président de la république au conseil
des ministres le 24 août
s'agissant la consultation la
consultation a déjà commencé avec un
certain nombre de parlementaires puisque
à 17 heures j'aurai l'occasion vous êtes
le bienvenu de discuter avec un certain
nombre de parlementaires des différentes
mesures et propositions qui doivent
figurer au titre de la relance
j'aurais demain une consultation avec
l'ensemble des partenaires sociaux la
demande du premier ministre pour
échanger avec eux sur les mesures
économiques les plus efficaces avec un
objectif l'emploi l'emploi et l'emploi
en particulier en priorité absolue
l'emploi des jeunes dès la rentrée
prochaine et la relance je veux vous
rassurer monsieur castellani c'est tout
de suite qu'elle a lieu ce que les
mesures du projet de loi de finances
rectificative numéro 3 vont être
immédiatement disponibles et efficaces
pour soutenir la croissance
un mot enfin sur le caractère durable de
cette relance
vous avez dit 20 % des budgets qui
seront consacrés à l'environnement et la
transition écologique dans le plan de
relance français est bien avec barbara
pompili la ministre la transition
écologique
nous souhaitons porter à 30% les crédits
de la relance qui seront consacrés à la
transition écologique notre relance sera
une relance verte
merci monsieur le ministre avant de lui
céder la parole je vais adresser à
monsieur eric straumann straumann pardon
nos félicitations
quand son élection à la tête de la ville
de colmar et lui adresser tous nos voeux
de succès chers collègues monsieur
straumann vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
je quitte la plus belle capitale au
monde pour prendre la première magistral
la première magistrature pardon de la
plus belle ville de france
c'est à dire colmar le seul premier
ministre vous avez annoncé dans votre
discours du 15 juillet une nouvelle
étape de la décentralisation avec la
nécessité de rendre rapidement plus
cohérente et plus efficace
l'organisation territoriale de ce
premier ministre vous avez vécu
plusieurs années en alsace dont vous
connaissez les particularismes la
création de la collectivité européenne
d'alsace a été un début de réponse au
gigantisme des grandes régions qui ne
tiennent pas compte des réalités
historiques et géographiques
vous avez évoqué le droit à la
différenciation monsieur le premier
ministre dans le cadre de ce droit la
différenciation je vous suggère de
fusionner les compétences de la région
et de la nouvelle collectivité
européenne d'alsace pour réduire le
mille feuille institutionnel
c'est une mesure qui va dans le bon sens
or avec un souci d'efficacité et un
souci aussi d'économie dans les coûts de
fonctionnement de nos collectivités
merci chers collègues la parole et à
madame jacqueline gourault ministre de
la cohésion des territoires et des
relations et des collectivités
territoriales
monsieur le député cher eric straumann
je tiens d'abord moi même à vous
exprimer mes félicitations pour votre
élection en tant que maire de colmar et
président de colmar agglomération
je vous avais fait le choix de
privilégier le mandat de maire et je
sais par expérience les satisfactions
que vous y trouverez en proximité avec
vos habitants alors bien sûr vous avez
parlé de différenciation vous avez parlé
de déco décentralisation pardon c'est
vrai que nous allons présenter au
conseil des ministres le 29 juillet un
nouvel outil visant à programmer un
projet de loi organique qui facilitera
le recours aux expérimentations
territoriales qui sont plébiscités sur
le terrain et je dois dire d'ailleurs
que l'alsace a été au fond une
expérience réussie et je vous remercie
de votre implication pour faire aboutir
ce projet bien sûr avec tous les
alsaciens ici présents dans l'hémicycle
car c'était un accord unanime et je
citerai vous le comprendrez aussi la
ministre brigitte klinkert alors
présidente du conseil départemental du
haut rhin
alors bien sûr ce le projet de loi que
nous allons organique nous allons
déposer et le premier ministre l'a
annoncé sera suivie d'une nouvelle étape
de décentralisation qui donnera lieu à
un prochain projet à un prochain projet
de loi est naturellement nous
discuterons de plein de propositions et
je ne suis pas étonné de celles que vous
avez fait cher eric straumann mais nous
en parlerons dans le cadre de cette loi
mais je voulais vous dire bien sûr que
je compte sur vous pour continuer à
travailler avec le gouvernement
comme vous l'avez toujours fait et à la
tête de votre collectivité territoriale
ce sera une grande joie de travailler
avec vous merci madame la ministre
oui madame la ministre je vous remercie
pour votre réponse et j'ai pris bonne
note que vous n'écartez pas l'hypothèse
d'une fusion entre la région et la
collectivité européenne d'alsace et mes
collègues aux prouesses des prochains
mois vont y travailler merci à vous
merci monsieur le député la parole est à
monsieur hubert julien laferrière merci
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse aux communistes affaires
étrangères monsieur le ministre
trouvez-vous pouvons nous détourner le
regard plus longtemps sur ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui en chine dans la
province du zhejiang 12 millions de
ouïghours qui depuis de nombreuses
années subissent persécution et
violences arrestations massives violent
travail forcé stérilisation forcée
les témoignages sont nombreux et il
annihile le doute s'il pouvait en rester
un un dossier sur le bureau du procureur
du tribunal pénal international les
travaux du chercheur allemand adrian z
qui se base sur des documents officiels
des autorités chinoises et puis il y a
ce témoignage dans libération ce matin
de cette enseignante ouigours exilé en
europe victimes de la stérilisation
forcée qui relate son expérience dans
les camps loin des centres de formation
professionnelle dont parle pékin où
l'étude détenus subissent les pires
exactions
n'ayons pas peur des mots il s'agit bien
ici d'une entreprise organisée et
institutionnalisés d'éradication d'une
population au motif selon les termes
mêmes utilisés par le régime qu'elle
affaiblit l'identité nationale et
l'identification à la race nationale
chinoise
oui mes chers collègues nous sommes
devant un crime contre l'humanité nous
sommes parlementaire notre devoir est
aussi de garantir le respect des
conventions internationales
c'est la raison pour laquelle avec
aurélien tâche et 30 parlementaires nous
avons écrit au président de la
république parce que l'impunité du
régime chinois dure depuis trop
longtemps
elle n'est plus acceptable en gardant le
silence alors que des femmes des hommes
et des enfants sont persécutés chaque
jour
nous nous rendrions complices de ces
exactions monsieur le ministre comment
la france compte l agir avec ses
partenaires européens pour que les
persécutions que subissent la communique
t ouïghours cesse immédiatement et
fassent l'objet de réparations à la
hauteur du préjudice subi le remercie
monsieur débuté la parole est à monsieur
jean yves le drian ministre de l'europe
et des affaires étrangères monsieur le
député julien laferrière la france
regarde avec beaucoup d'attention
l'ensemble des témoignages l'ensemble
des documents qui sont relayées par la
presse singulièrement aujourd'hui et qui
sont relayés aussi par les organisations
de défense des droits de l'homme sur la
situation au tignet ce ce qui
transparaît de l'ensemble des
informations que nous avons ou connu
l'horizon ce sont des camps
d'internement pour les ouigours des
détentions massive des disparitions le
travail forcé des séries lisation force
et la destruction du patrimoine culturel
ouigours et en particulier des lieux de
culte
la surveillance de la population et plus
globalement tout le système répressif
mis en place dans ces deux régions
nous avons exprimé à de nombreuses
reprises vous vu nos déclarations
nos braves préoccupation à l'égard de la
situation des droits de l'homme dans
cette province en demandant
spécifiquement est officiellement je le
redis ici la fermeture des camps
d'internement
toutes ces pratiques sont inacceptables
car elles vont contre les principes
universels inscrits dans les grande
convention mondiale des droits de
l'homme et donc nous les condamnons avec
beaucoup de fermeté
à chaque à chaque occasion dans nos
contacts bilatéraux le président de la
république moi même d'autres avec les
autorités chinoises nous rappelons cette
exigence et nous le faisons aussi dans
les enceintes de l'onu telles que le
conseil des droits de l'homme pour
appeler les autorités à mettre fin aux
détentions dans des camps au soutien
dans l'immédiat nous demandons tout
simplement à ce que la chine permettent
l'accès des observateurs indépendants
internationaux dans cette zone et
qu'elles permettent aussi à la haute
commissaire aux droits de l'homme de
visiter le signifiant dans toute liberté
merci monsieur le ministre la parole à
monsieur hubert wulfranc monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
ministres la relance la relance du
chemin de fer toujours rien toujours
rien zéro les organisations syndicales
les organisations patronales la
convention citoyenne vous interpelle en
urgence de toute part 0 votre loi
mobilité 2018 en 2020 c'est l'incapacité
de recapitaliser la société anonyme sncf
toujours 0 côtier direction par contre
côté direction la casse continue je
prenne quelques exemples dans le fret la
guerre de triage de grande synthe
menacée de fermeture à la fin de l'année
je parle même pas de celle de
sotteville-lès-rouen
dans ma circonscription qui se dit li
qui fuit les petites lignes
les petites lignes capillaire prenons la
petite ligne mont dore volvic qui
transportent les bouteilles d'eau
menacée de fermeture à la fin de l'année
quant à kankan tôt perpignan rungis il
ne roule pas depuis un an
alors les emplois dans les régions
l'activité
en fait l'activité des territoires dans
chacun se gargarise le par le terme
territoire employés à nombreuses
reprises ces derniers jours et ces
dernières semaines et bien l'emploi les
territoires périclite un ce moment même
alors le le président a dit le président
a dit vouloir développer massivement je
cite le fret ferroviaire le premier
minstre vous même monsieur le premier
ministre avait dit vouloir accélérer les
projets réseaux dont la sauvegarde des
petites lignes
alors nous les députés communistes vous
demande simplement quelles sont vos
décisions d'urgence vos arbitrage
imminent merci chers collègues
la parole est à monsieur jean baptiste
du barry ministre délégué chargé des
transports
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
wulfranc la relance du chemin de fer
s'est depuis 2010 est monsieur le député
ou le franc avec 35 milliards d' une
dette devenue insoutenable
fruit d'un surinvestissement des lignes
à grande vitesse bas sous investissement
chronique sur le réseau secondaire et
donc la relance c'est depuis 2010 7 15
milliards de dotations publiques à la
sncf chaque année monsieur le député 3
milliards d'investissements dans le
réseau ferroviaire c'était un milliard
il ya encore dix ans et ça continue
puisque avec les petites lignes vous
l'avez cité nous avons signé deux
protocoles d'accord pour sauvegarder les
9000 kilomètres de petites lignes
ferroviaires deux protocoles signés avec
les régions vous le savez centre val de
loire et grand test pour plus d'un
milliard d'euros dans une dynamique
partenariale et encore aujourd'hui
encore aujourd'hui les travaux étaient
en cours et puis la relance du chemin de
fer monsieur le député bull france et le
fret ferroviaire vous l'avez cité le pré
le président de la république le premier
ministre se sont exprimés de façon
extrêmement clair sur le sujet ce sont
d'abord des investissements massifs qui
vont être entrepris dans le cadre
du plan de relance pour mieux articuler
non seulement au niveau français mais
européen le chemin de fer et les
infrastructures notamment portuaires il
ya de gros manques et de goran tard à ce
sujet c'est évidemment la création de
modèles économiques beaucoup plus
robustes et nous avons vocation nous
subventionner a déjà le transport
combiné nous avons vocation à accélérer
encore l'action sur les wagons isolés
vous savez c'est un sujet que vous
connaissez particulièrement bien assez
la création de nouvelles autoroutes
ferroviaires notamment sur le perpignan
régis madame panneaux notamment sur le
père finn réagissent et nous aurons deux
d'être des annonces extrêmement
concrètes à faire prochainement avec le
premier ministre
merci monsieur le ministre la parole à
monsieur alain david
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre c'est à l'arraché qu'un
accord a été trouvé tôt ce matin entre
les 27 pays de l'union européenne pour
un plan destiné à soutenir nos économies
durement affectées par l'épidémie de
covin 19 le premier ministre espagnol
pedro sanchez avait initialement
préconisé le montant de 500 milliards
mais l'égoïsme des quatre pays dits
frugaux les pays-bas l'autriche le
danemark et la suède a finalement limité
l'ambition à 390 milliards assortis qui
plus est de nouveau raz b pour les
contributions de ces quatre pays
radin la vigilance doit être de mise
malgré la satisfaction de voir
l'allemagne longtemps alignés sur cette
dévastatrice position de rigueur
budgétaire se convertir enfin à l'idée
de nécessaire relance de l'économie
européenne indispensable mutualisation
de la dette
on peut également déplorer que cet
accord s'accompagne de contreparties
négative comme les coupes sèches sur les
budgets européens de la santé de
l'agriculture du numérique de la
recherche ou d'erasmus et n'explore
toujours pas l'idée de ressources
propres pour l'union européenne comme un
impôt sur les multinationales ou une
taxe sur les transactions financières
pour autant saluons cette avancée vers
une europe plus solidaire
espérons que l'union européenne
n'exigera pas de nouvelles réformes
structurelles
en contrepartie dans les prochains mois
ainsi vous pouvez vous nous détailler
monsieur le premier ministre
quels seront les projets qui
bénéficieront de ce plan bénéfice de
tous les français
merci chers collègues la parole à
monsieur jean yves le drian ministre de
l'europe et des affaires étrangères
monsieur le député alain david e vous
avez souligné l'ampleur de l'accord qui
est intervenu cette nuit il y encore
quelques quelques semaines on pouvait
lire certains acteurs politiques de
l'union européenne demandait à ce que le
budget de l'union européenne soit réduit
à 1 % aujourd'hui
après les accords de cette nuit nous
sommes proche de 2%
et cela a été rendu possible grâce à
l'adoption du plan de relance sans
précédent
vous avez bien voulu le reconnaître dans
l'histoire j'ai connu plusieurs
quinquennat et je connais dans le
quinquennat précédent et dans le
quinquennat
tu avances le précédent des tentatives
pour aboutir à ce résultat est à ce mot
là il n'y avait pas les alliances
nécessaires que nous avons pu obtenir
aujourd'hui donc c'est un résultat sans
précédent sans précédent sur le montant
sans précédent dans les modalités
puisque l'endettement commun est actée
sans précédent non plus sur la rapidité
puisque je vous rappelle que
l'initiative franco allemande elle date
du 18 mai en deux mois on a pu inverser
une logique qui au départ ne nous était
pas favorable
alors monsieur le député vous nous
demander d'être vigilants
nous le saurons y compris dans le
dispositif d'acceptation et de
validation des plans de relance de
chacun des états qui sera soumis à la
commission comme d'ailleurs pour les
projets régionaux des fonds structurels
qui nécessite une majorité qualifiée
mais pas une un veto et nous serons
aussi très vigilants pour éviter que ce
plan de relance
nobert le plan de le coût financier
pluriannuel qui a été aussi acté et qui
prévoient qu'ils ne prévoient pas
monsieur le député une réduction de la
pac ni une diminution du programme
erasmus puisque le premier programme
erasmus que vous citez passe de 14
milliards à 21
ça s'appelle une augmentation mais en
tout cas merci de votre soutien et de la
compréhension que vous faites de ce plan
merci monsieur le ministre avant de lui
céder la parole je veux adresser à
monsieur louis aliot nos félicitations
et nos voeux de succès à la tête de la
ville de perpignan où il a été élu si
j'avais la parole merci président
monsieur le premier ministre
la france est le théâtre d'une ultra
violence quotidienne désormais endémique
dans certaines zones
ces dernières années les gouvernements
multipliaient les grenelles les plans
marshall et autres ségur sans jamais
prendre la mesure réelle du chantier
majeur de l'insécurité de l'incivilité
ou pour le dire plus crûment de
l'ensauvagement de nos quartiers
perpignan que vous connaissez bien n'est
d'ailleurs pas épargné par cette
situation
nous avons besoin de policiers certes
mais surtout d'un soutien indéfectible
de l'état nous ne vous demandons pas de
vous lancer dans un concours lépine de
la meilleure idée ou d'une énième
promesse
les français attendent du concret après
l'épisode honteux des tchétchènes de
dijon trop de scènes de violence hors
norme filtre sur les réseaux sociaux
avec des dérives graves comme 1,5 point
où les habitants face à la carence de
l'état sont obligés de négocier avec les
voyous pour acheter une tranquillité
bien précaire en l'absence de l'état ils
finiront par se défendre eux-mêmes avec
toutes les conséquences que cela
engendrera ils ne sont pas des lignes
statistiques ses victimes mais des
victimes d'un terrorisme du quotidien
qu'il faut nommer comme il se doit un
terrorisme du quotidien auxquels sont
confrontés tous ceux qui tiennent l'état
à bout de bras pompiers policiers
soignants ou enseignants monsieur le
premier ministre la vraie guerre doit
être menée contre ces voyous
certains quartiers sont littéralement
contrôlé par un trafic de drogue
tentaculaire qui fait des victimes
directes et collatéral enrichissant
quelques caïds qui alimente un sentiment
d'impunité inadmissible dans une
république digne de ce nom vous êtes
allés à la courneuve pour rappeler les
fondamentaux de l'ordre public
républicain depuis trop longtemps mis à
mal et nous nous en félicitons
mais au delà des mots quelles sont vos
intentions réelles et quels moyens
êtes vous prêt à mettre en place pour
mener cette guerre à perpignan comme
ailleurs vous êtes attendus sur ce sujet
comme tant d'autres merci merci la
parole est à monsieur gérald darmanin
ministre de l'intérieur le président les
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
permettez moi tout d'abord et je
l'espère en votre nom à tous d'avoir une
pensée pour cette aide-soignante de lyon
dont le drame est particulièrement
horrible et dont je remercie les forces
de secours les forces de police est
intervenue immédiatement
nous espérons tous que les personnes qui
ont responsable ce meurtre soit
évidemment rapidement sanctionnés et
châtiés
monsieur monsieur le député vous avez
parlé de perpignan et vous avez parlé du
reste de la france
papillon et on le sait le centre du
monde et vous avez connu un fait divers
dans votre commune vous avez connu vous
avez connu dans notre commune a fait
divers particulier le 16 juillet dernier
j'aurais d'ailleurs remercié les forces
de police d'être intervenus
immédiatement quatre interpellations
et puis des gardes à vue immédiate une
justice très réactive et oui s'il y a
des faits divers particulièrement
révélateur du duc de la crise d'autorité
qui existe dans nos villes
les policiers les pompiers sont présents
lorsque nous avons besoin d'eux et ils
protègent la population et vous avez
raison il faut être devant eux et au
soutien entier non seulement du
parlement de la majorité mais du
gouvernement vous demander des moyens à
perpignan monsieur le député il est vrai
qu'il y avait moins dix sept policiers
au 30 juin au 30 septembre à la demande
du premier ministre il y en aura sept de
plus que les effectifs budgétisé de
votre commissariat et dans toute la
france c'est un milliard d'euros qui a
été augmenté depuis trois ans dans le
budget de la sécurité sous l'autorité de
monsieur collomb est ce nous ont aidé et
christophe castaner à qui je veux rendre
hommage aujourd'hui et dès l'année
prochaine
c'est des moyens supplémentaires pour la
police pour la gendarmerie pour les
pompiers
mais plus que des moyens monsieur le
député c'est l'ensemble de l'autorité
par la voix du gouvernement et par la
voie du parlement qui doit être
réaffirmé et oui les voyous n'auront
jamais le droit de cité or on république
à perpignan ou ailleurs merci monsieur
le ministre la parole d'un monsieur paul
christophe monsieur le président mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
madame brigitte bourguignon ministre
délégué chargé de l'autonomie madame la
ministre la loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale pour 2020 prévoit
l'indemnisation du congé dit de proches
aidants permettant ainsi d'améliorer
l'articulation entre leur vie
personnelle professionnelle et leurs
idées dans ayant défendu un texte
proposant la mise en oeuvre d'un tel
dispositif dès 2018 vous comprendrez
pourquoi cette disposition ne tient tout
particulièrement à coeur
vous le savez depuis le début du mandat
la situation des proches aidants occupe
une place spécifique dans mon travail
parlementaire comme au quotidien j'ai
déjà eu l'occasion comme beaucoup
d'entre nous en qualité d'une locale
puis aujourd'hui comme député de
vérifier le rôle essentiel que joue
ainsi au quotidien plus de 8 millions de
femmes et d'hommes au service des plus
fragiles
par ailleurs la crise sanitaire que nous
vivons ainsi que la transition
démographique qui nous attend nous
oblige à reconnaître à sa juste valeur
le rôle primordial dans notre société
ainsi j'ai eu l'occasion de me réjouir
de l'adoption de la stratégie de
mobilisation et de soutien des proches
aidants proposé par le gouvernement qui
traduisait enfin une véritable politique
publique en leur faveur
parmi les six principales mesures
décidées pour simplifier soulager leur
quotidien figuraient outre le droit au
répit et des dispositions retraite
l'indemnisation du congé proches aidants
nous avons donc saluer cette disposition
novatrice longtemps demandée par les
acteurs du médico-social le monde
associatif ainsi que bien entendu par
les familles concernées
pour autant aujourd'hui pour que ces
auxiliaires de l'ombre puisse
véritablement devenir visible aux yeux
de la société il nous faut agir
en effet plus de six mois sont passés et
nous sommes toujours latent du décret
d'application qui doit préciser les
conditions et les montant de cette aide
madame la ministre connaissant votre
soutien à nos travaux en faveur des
aidants et votre engagement constant au
profit des plus fragiles et vous en
mesure de nous préciser la date de mise
en oeuvre de ce dispositif tant attendu
par ces femmes et ces hommes qui
quotidiennement oeuvre en toute humilité
et bienveillance pour soutenir leurs
proches en difficulté merci chers
collègues
la parole est à mme brigitte bourguignon
ministre délégué chargé de l'onu
merci merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés
monsieur député paul christophe vous me
faites l'honneur de me permettre de
répondre à ma première question au
gouvernement et je vous en remercie
je connais votre engagement personnel en
faveur de la reconnaissance du rôle et
de la place des proches aidants dans
notre société je le partage et je sais
aussi que cette question et cette
préoccupation pour avoir présidé la
commission des affaires sociales de
cette belle assemblée est partagée
surtout les bandes au delà des clivages
politiques
développer un pacte social qui
garantissent la considération et la
qualité de vie de ceux d'entre nous qui
ont un déficit d'autonomie impose aussi
une juste reconnaissance de ceux qui
s'engagent dans l'accompagnement d'un
proche
évitant ainsi le placement dans un
établissement spécialisé ce le sens de
la stratégie agir pour les aidants
présenté par le gouvernement le 23
octobre dernier est doté de 400 millions
d'euros sur la période 2020 2022
l'un des piliers de cette stratégie vise
à couvrir à ouvrir de nouveaux droits
sociaux aux proches aidantes
cela s'est traduit dès la loi de
financement de sécurité sociale pour
2020 avec la création d'un congé de
proches aidants indemnisés vous
m'interrogez sur la date de publication
du décret d'application qui doit
préciser le montant et les conditions de
l'indemnisation du congé
j'entends votre impatience et sachez
monsieur le député que ça a été la
première de mes questions ce décret sera
publié au cours du mois de septembre au
plus tard pour permettre une application
au 1er octobre
comme cela est prévu par la loi j'y
veillerai personnellement
tout comme je veillerai aussi aux
premiers bilans de mise en oeuvre de la
stratégie de mobilisation de soutien aux
proches aidants
le parlement et l'ensemble des parties
prenantes ils seront associés
je vous remercie merci la parole est un
monsieur bastien la chaux merci monsieur
le président monsieur le premier
ministre le gouvernement nous a d'abord
dit que les masques et est inutile parce
qu'il n'y en avait pas
ce qu'il était incapable de planifier la
production et la distribution
puis vous avez organisé le déconfinement
les masques étaient devenus utile mais
facultatif nous vous avions pourtant
demandé de les rendre obligatoires pour
prévenir une nouvelle vague de
l'épidémie
à présent que les indicateurs nous
alertent les masques devienne
obligatoire mais payant la presse a
estimé leur coût à 228 euros par mois
pour une famille avec deux enfants
une amende de 135 euros puni ceux qui
n'en porterai pas alors que notre pays
s'enfonce dans la crise sociale
croyez vous vraiment que nos
compatriotes puissent se permettre de
dépenser plus de 200 euros par mois pour
se protéger et protéger les autres
228 euros c'est une montagne pour qu'ils
gagnent le smic c'est une montagne pour
beaucoup d'habitants de ma
circonscription en seine saint denis à
aubervilliers à pantin ou 30 à 40% de la
population vit sous le seuil de pauvreté
où beaucoup ont aujourd'hui des
difficultés à payer leur loyer leurs
dépenses alimentaires même vont-ils
devoir choisir entre nourrir leurs
enfants et acheter des masques
si le masque est obligatoire ce n'est
pas aux familles d'en payer le prix
en tant qu'êtres humains nous sommes
égaux devant la maladie nous devons être
égaux devant la protection la santé est
un droit
l'aide ponctuelle aux plus modestes que
le ministre bruno le maire dit
aujourd'hui envisagée irait dans le bon
sens mais elle est trop tardive et elle
est surtout insuffisante
il faut garantir la gratuité des masques
c'est ce que dit le conseil scientifique
j'ai déposé avec le groupe de la france
insoumise une proposition de loi pour
garantir cette gratuité
dès le 28 avril dernier monsieur le
premier ministre
quand vous déciderez vous à nous écouter
et à rendre les masques gratuits
merci monsieur les buts et la parole et
à monsieur olivier véran ministre des
solidarités et de la santé monsieur le
député bastia lachaud le masque que je
viens d'en lever pour vous répondre
coûte 1 euro 80 et il est lavable 30
fois
les masques grand public qui ont été
développées notamment par les
entreprises françaises à l'initiative
conjointe de mon ministère et daniel
spagnou rina chez qui a travaillé sans
relâche
non seulement nous a permis d'être
capable de mobiliser un très grand
nombre de masques en des délais
extrêmement courts pour protéger la
population française mais également
disposer de masse qui ont plusieurs
avantages destinés au grand public par
rapport à des masques chirurgicaux
d'abord il n'y a pas de problème de
recyclage
il n'y a pas de problème de masques
qu'on va jeter parts par ailleurs trop
souvent dans la rue et le coup on est
beaucoup plus maîtrisé puisque ils sont
lavables et réutilisables
un nombre important de fois vous posez
la question monsieur le député de
l'accessibilité au public précaire de ce
type de masque sachez qu'avant même que
les masques et étaient rendus
obligatoires et dès le début du mois de
mai la france a envoyé cinq millions de
masques à destination des populations
précaires distribués par les
associations par les ccas par les
mairies par les préfectures
[Applaudissements]
ces envois vont reprendre à partir de la
semaine prochaine et non seulement elles
vont reprendre dans les communes les
ccas et les sites associatifs mais il va
également y avoir des envois postaux qui
seront effectués jusque chez les gens
lorsque ce sera nécessaire pour nous
assurer qu'ils bénéficient de masques de
protection et qui n'est pas pour cela à
débourser le moindre euro et puis
monsieur le député j'ai eu l'occasion de
répondre tout à l'heure il y aura
également des prescriptions qui pourront
être faites au public vulnérable d'un
point de vue de la santé
ces deux millions de français qui y
verront pour le coup des masques
chirurgicaux plus protecteur encore qui
seront remboursés par l'assurance
maladie vous voyez nous mettons nous
portons une grande attention aux publics
les plus fragiles et aux plus précaires
et nous invitons évidemment les français
à utiliser autant que possible des
masques qui sont lavables qui sont
réutilisables qui sont recyclables je
regarde la ministre de la transition
énergétique qui acquiesce de la tête et
à la bien raison merci monsieur le
ministre avant de lui céder
si vous voulez monsieur là jour 5
millions de masques pour 9 millions de
pauvres
une goutte d'eau dans un océan de misère
merci monsieur le député avant de lui
donner la parole je veux adresser nos
félicitations de succès à monsieur
sébastien leclerc qui a été élu à la
tête de la ville de lisieux
tous nos voeux de succès chers collègues
vous avez la parole merci monsieur le
président je voudrais d'abord remercier
le président de notre groupe d'amis abad
est associé christian jacob
ainsi que tous mes collègues députés les
républicains de me laisser interroger le
gouvernement
pour ma dernière séance de questions
d'actualité lundi prochain je passerai
le relais à ma suppléante nathalie porte
qui viendra siéger parmi vous avec
enthousiasme et détermination
monsieur le premier ministre après des
mois de mouvements sociaux dans la
plupart de nos départements
les sapeurs pompiers professionnels
avaient reçu l'engagement du précédent
ministre de l'intérieur sur une
augmentation de leur prime de feu pour
la portée du plafond actuel de 19 % à 25
% depuis janvier indépendamment du
contexte sanitaire de notre pays le
projet de décret a été soumis à l'avis
de diverses instances
mais le conseil d'évaluation des normes
s'est opposé à ce décret en soulignant
l'absence d'accompagnement de l'état aux
collectivités soit par l'octroi de
nouveaux financements soit par
l'allégement de charges existantes
alors que l'ampleur de la revalorisation
a été déterminé par le gouvernement
jeudi dernier gérald harman a annoncé
avoir signé le décret permettant cette
revalorisation
comme l'indiqué le président de la cnil
cela représente la moitié du chemin
le coût annuel de l'augmentation de la
prime de feu est évalué à 80 millions
d'euros
l'état ne peut pas laisser croire aux
sapeurs pompiers qu'ils obtiendront
cette augmentation sans consentir à y
participer lui-même lé président d'ace
10 dans le calvados comme partout en
france demande à ce que soit supprimée
la surcotisation à la cnra cl ce qui
permettrait ainsi d'assurer une partie
du financement de l'augmentation de la
prime de feu monsieur le premier
ministre mercredi dernier vous
présentiez comme étant l'homme des
territoires
vous avez dès maintenant l'occasion de
passer de la parole aux actes
décider rapidement de la fin de la
surcotisation cnra cl pour transformer
la promesse d'augmenter la prime de feu
en une réalité finançable par les 10 de
france et chaque collègue la parole à
monsieur gérald darmanin ministre de
l'intérieur mesdames et messieurs les
députés monsieur le député vous avez
raison après de nombreux mois de conflit
social mon prédécesseur a réglée par une
négociation avec les syndicats de
sapeurs pompiers dont vous savez qu'il
ya une gestion particulière à la fois
parce que les dix qui sont de véritables
collectivités locales gèrent les
équipements et le personnel et l'état
qui travaille en direct évidemment pour
la sécurité civile de nos concitoyens se
décrit aurait dû être signée à la fin du
mois d'août devant la multilatérale
désolé sow syndicales que j'ai pu
recevoir et dans divers déplacements
depuis dix jours
j'ai signé effectivement ce décret
cosigné par d'autres ministres du
gouvernement et il est désormais à la
fin du mois de juillet totalement dans
le texte que pourront demain avoir comme
avant c'est sympa pompiers si les
collectivités locales qui sont des dix
délibère parce qu'ils doivent prendre
une délibération vous le savez positive
pour pouvoir accorder cette prime de feu
et cette prime de feu qui prévoit une
augmentation substantielle chaque mois
pour les sapeurs pompiers je crois que
l'autonomie des collectivités locales
que vous défendrez depuis longtemps
démontre que nous ne pouvons évidemment
pas dans un tel de textes réglementaires
prévoir non seulement de compensation ou
de force fait aux collectivités locales
que sont les 10 mais j'ai entendu la
demande des départements de france
singulièrement celle du président
dominique bussereau et je recevrai le
président du sro et le bureau de l'adf
pour en discuter avec la ministre de la
cohésion des territoires
évidemment pour voir comment nous
pouvons accompagner les 10 de france
vous avez une proposition qui est celle
de la suppression de la surcotisation il
ya une part salariale dans cette
cotisation qui serait du pouvoir d'achat
donné directement aux sapeurs pompiers
puis une part patronale de tiers qui ne
couvre pas le montant général de cette
prime de feu mais dans une négociation
que nous pourrions avoir avec le
ministre des comptes sociaux avec la
ministre des cohésions des territoires
et avec le ministère de l'intérieur sous
l'autorité du premier ministre
c'est une possibilité de discussion
cependant dès aujourd'hui il faut qu'on
le sache
les collectivités locales peuvent
prendre ses délibérations et augmenter
les primes de
sapeurs-pompiers merci monsieur le
ministre la parole est à madame des
prêts audibert merci monsieur le
président mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur bruno le
maire mise de l'économie des finances et
de la relance monsieur le ministre la
relance de l'économie seul affaire de
tous nous sommes désormais quasiment
dans un état d'urgence économique est
lancé dans une course contre la montre
nous parlementaires y prenons notre part
avec un groupe de travail
haddock nous vous remettons ce jour une
première sélection de vins cette mesure
qui peuvent être mises en oeuvre
rapidement et destinés à simplifier les
relations entreprises administrations et
les procédures
il y en aura d'autres le gouvernement de
son côté a décidé d'aider notre
industrie par une baisse très attendu
des impôts de production nous approuvons
unanimement ce plan de relance dont une
partie soit 10 milliards va concerner la
baisse de la contribution sur la valeur
ajoutée des entreprises dès 2021
j'en profite pour saluer aussi bien
évidemment l'accord des 27 qui témoigne
de la naissance d'une solidarité
financière européenne et assure le
financement de notre plan de relance
je vis dans un territoire d'industrie où
le mot d'ordre pendant des décennies fut
la mobilisation du potentiel fiscal des
entreprises avec les dégâts que l'on
connaît en termes de délocalisation de
chômage de colère de montée du populisme
et de scepticisme européen je veux
attirer votre attention monsieur le
ministre sur la contribution foncière
des entreprises cfe qui pétait qui
pénalise aussi comme la cvae la
compétitivité des industries ainsi un
bâtiment et qualifie d'industriels quand
il abrite un investissement de
production supérieure à 500 mille euros
il est dès lors deux fois plus taxées
qu'un bâtiment dédié au seul stockage de
produits souvent d'importation on ne
peut mieux lester la compétitivité cela
paraît aussi illogique alors qu'on
ambitionne de relocaliser il semble
indispensable de recréer au moins une
équité fiscale
monsieur le ministre êtes vous prêt à
aller jusqu'au bout et donné un autre
signe fort à nos entreprises
industrielles qui produisent et
contribuer significativement à l'emploi
je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est à
monsieur bruno le maire ministre de
l'économie des finances et de la relance
madame la députée des préaux de berre il
ya de bons impôts qui sont juste qu'ils
sont efficaces et il y à de mauvais
impôt qui sont injustes et qui pénalise
nos entreprises les impôts de production
sont un mauvais impôt est pour vous dire
le fond de ma pensée
un impôt stupide parce que c'est un
impôt qui pèse sur les entreprises
avant même qu'elle ait fait des
bénéfices l'entreprise s'installe elle
ouvre ses bâtiments l'install ces robots
elle fait venir ses salariés et elles
payent des impôts avant même d'avoir
fait le premier euro de bénéfice n'allez
pas chercher ailleurs
l'une des raisons principales de la
délocalisation et de la
désindustrialisation de la france
c'est pour ça que nous avons décidé avec
le premier ministre avec le président de
la république une baisse massive et sans
précédent des impôts de production dans
le plan de relance que nous vous
présenterons le 24 août prochain
nous allons engager 10 milliards d'euros
de baisses d'impôts de production dès le
1er janvier 2021 soit 20 milliards
d'euros sur deux ans de baisse d'impôts
de production pour rattraper le
différentiel que nous avons avec
l'allemagne où les impôts de production
sont je le rappelle cinq fois moins
élevés qu'en france
nous allons privilégier la cotisation
sur la valeur ajoutée qui est un des
impôts qui pèsent le plus sur
l'industrie vous venez du pas de calais
d'un territoire industriel et vous savez
à quel point ça pénalise nos industries
et de territoires industriels
nous allons compenser intégralement et
de manière dynamique les régions qui
vont perdre la recette de cet impôt de
production pour que les régions et nos
territoires ne soient pas pénalisés par
ce choix
et puis nous allons ouvrir d'ici
quelques instants et dans les semaines
qui viennent
la discussion avec les parlementaires
avec les élus locaux pour voir quelles
sont les autres impôts de production qui
mériterait d'être baisser la promesse du
président de la république sera tenu
non relocaliseront nos activités
industrielles par la baisse des impôts
de production merci monsieur le ministre
la parole est à madame laurence dumont
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre pour la première fois
depuis 20 ans il ya en france moins de
prisonniers que de places de prison
conséquence d'une crise sanitaire sans
précédent ce qui était hier impossible
est devenu réalité en deux mois de
confinement le nombre de personnes
détenues a été réduit de 13500 cette
situation fait naître un fol espoir car
si elle résulte de circonstances
exceptionnelles elle impose une évidence
incontestable réduire la population
carcérale prendre en charge en milieu
libre
ceux qui peuvent l'être n'est ni
déraisonnable ni dangereux
c'est au contraire une mesure de salut
public nous demandons donc dans le
domaine des prisons comme dans d'autre
que les enseignements soient tirés qu'à
la gestion de l'urgence succès d'une
véritable politique de déflation
carcéral pour garantir l'encellulement
individuel des conditions de détention
dignes et favoriser la prise en charge
en milieu libre en milieu libre de ceux
qui peuvent l'être
nous attendons de la france qu'elle ne
soit plus pointés du doigt par les
instances européennes pour les
traitements inhumains et dégradants
qu'elle inflige aux prisonniers
le moment est venu l'occasion est là ne
la manquez pas monsieur le premier
ministre
ces mots auxquels j'adhère totalement
sont ceux de votre garde des sceaux il a
en effet signé début juin une lettre
ouverte au président de la république
appelant à une véritable politique de
déflation carcéral ma demande est donc
simple mais forte en son absence
aujourd'hui fait en sorte monsieur le
premier ministre votre garde des sceaux
met en oeuvre aujourd'hui ce qu'il a
demandé hier pour que les conditions de
détention en france soit enfin digne
merci madame la députée la parole de
monsieur gabriel atteint secrétaire
d'état porte parole du gouvernement
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la députée
laurence dumont je vous prie d'excuser
l'absence de mon collègue garde des
sceaux eric dupond moretti qui est
actuellement au sénat pour l'examen en
lecture définitive de la proposition de
loi visant à lutter contre les violences
conjugales et je pense que mon collègue
aurait aimé être présent pour vous
répondre parce que dès son discours de
passation il a eu l'occasion de parler
de s'exprimer très fortement sur ces
questions de politique carcérale son
premier déplacement s'est fait dans un
établissement pénitentiaire et je crois
qu'ils hier en audition devant la
commission des lois de l'assemblée
nationale il a eu l'occasion de revenir
sur ces questions là est ce qui ressort
de ces déclarations c'est que les mots
que vous avez évoquées qui étaient les
siens dans une lettre avant qu'il soit
nommé il pourrait tout à fait les
reprenons c'est aujourd'hui en tout cas
c'est ce qui lui sert de boussole pour
avancer aujourd'hui dans son action je
parlerai forcément moins bien que lui de
ces sujets là est moins bien qu'il ne
l'a fait hier et le fera sans doute
demain dans cet hémicycle où dans des
rencontres avec vous mais il me semble
qu'il a été très clair sur le fait que
nous ne pouvons nous résoudre à ce que
la france terre des droits de l'homme
soient régulièrement condamnée par la
cour européenne des droits de l'homme
pour le traitement de ces personnes
incarcérées dans son pays ce qui nous
invite à continuer à avancer dans le
sens de la loi de programmation sur la
justice dans le cadre des alternatives à
l'incarcération
nous avons augmenté depuis trois ans
date le travail d'intérêt général comme
sanction pénale de 16%
le recours au bracelet électronique de
20% évidemment nous allons poursuivre
avec le bloc pen qui vient d'entrer en
vigueur pleinement qui va nous permettre
d'avancer et puis l'amélioration des
conditions de détention des détenus là
dessus il a aussi été très clair et
l'arrêt de la cour européenne des droits
de l'homme invitent demande a présenté
un plan d'action sur ce sujet là ce sera
fait avant la fin de l'année il l'a dit
et puis évidemment la poursuite du plan
immobilier je crois que la première
tranche de 7000 places est déjà bien
engagé 2000 ont déjà été sortis depuis
le début de ce quinquennat vous voyez
que c'est sur ces trois piliers que nous
allons continuer à avancer je sais que
eric dupond-moretti aura l'occasion de
revenir sur ces sujets je vous remercie
merci monsieur le ministre la parole à
madame valérie opel tu as pendant 22 ans
on parle de moi non non c'est madame du
mans qui a quelques secondes de jeu je
n'ai hélas oublié dont vous avez la
parole oui monsieur le ministre moi je
regrette que cette question absolument
essentiel n'est même pas été évoquée par
le garde des sceaux dans un s'unit son
interview au journal du dimanche il y a
deux jours et donc c'est pour ça que la
question méritait d'être posée et
réaffirmé aujourd'hui je mens merci
merci avec mes excuses renouveler la
parole est à madame valérie au paint
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre de la
culture le samedi 18 juillet les
françaises et les français ont vu la
cathédrale de nantes s'embraser la
tragédie à laquelle nous assistions le
15 avril 2019 lorsqu'un incendie ravage
à notre dame de paris recommençait sous
nos yeux devant les nantaises et les
nantais impuissants les grandes orgues
rescapés de la révolution des
bombardements de 1943 et d'un incendie
en 1972 qui toucha déjà cette cathédrale
ont entièrement brûlé
dans la matinée de ce samedi comme la
grande verrière datant de l'époque
d'anne de bretagne
le parquet de nantes a saisi la police
judiciaire d'une enquête du chef d'
incendies volontaires
l' enquête est en cours je tiens à
saluer devant la représentation
nationale
toutes les équipes d'intervention et le
formidable travail des pompiers qui ont
sur maîtriser rapidement le feu
à l'immense tristesse de la communauté
catholique s'ajoute une immense
tristesse de l'ensemble des français le
patrimoine de pierre et le patrimoine
humain sont touchés au coeur avec cet
incendie je salue la célérité avec
laquelle monsieur le premier ministre
vous êtes venus sur nantes
accompagné de madame la ministre de la
culture et de monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur pour suivre les opérations
l'état est propriétaire de la cathédrale
l'état va prendre en charge les travaux
de restauration
la fondation du patrimoine d'ailleurs a
déjà lancé une souscription pour le
remplacement de l'orgue un plan
cathédrale a été initiée après l
incendie de notre dame de paris et mis
en place par le ministre de la culture
pouvez vous nous dire madame la ministre
où en est ce plan et quelles mesures
allez vous adopter pour restaurer la
cathédrale de nantes et éviter la
destruction d'autres patrimoine en
france
je vous remercie madame la députée la
parole d'harlem roselyne bachelot
ministre de la culture ce président
mesdames et messieurs les députés madame
la députée valérie opel tu vous étiez
devant la cathédrale de nantes et vous
partagiez l'émotion des nantaises et des
nantais de ceux qui croient au ciel et
de ceux qui n'y croient pas car akkaz et
dral saint pierre et saint paul est un
symbole emblématique de cette ville et
de toute la région
effectivement beaucoup de pièces
irremplaçable ont été détruites
vous avez évoqué le grand orgue la
verrière les stalles le tableau
d'hippolyte flandre a représentant
l'évêque sinclair guérissant les
aveugles on pourrait peut-être tous
aller prier devant ce tableau pour y
voir plus clair
effectivement il y a un plan cathédrale
et un plan de mise en sécurité de
l'ensemble des 87 cathédrale et des 89
afin dé faisant partie des 89 grands
établissements cultuelle dont l'état est
propriétaire
l'urgence va être de mettre en sécurité
l'ensemble de ces 89 patrice et 89
élément tout à fait cruciaux de notre
patrimoine
alors d'abord effectivement de mobiliser
les acteurs responsables de la sécurité
de faire en sorte que toutes les
installations électriques soient
vérifiées et que les cathédrales soient
toutes dotées de systèmes de détection
d'incendié de détection de fumée que les
plans d'évacuation des oeuvres soient
mises en oeuvre et parfaitement est
parfaitement cohérent mais nous ne
faisons pas d'illusions c'est pas
seulement une question d'argent
la mise en sécurité des cathédrales et
quelque chose de complexe parce que ce
n'est pas un musée
ce n'est pas un château qu'on visite
c'est un lieu de culte c'est un lieu de
prière de partage dans lequel on rentre
sans sens évidemment sans discrimination
et en toute liberté
comment mettre en sécurité avec des
détecteurs de fumée une nef qui fait
37,5 m de hauteur
on voit les difficultés c'est donc la
responsabilité de tous et de toutes
de garder la sécurité de nos cathédrales
qui sont effectivement un patrimoine
commun irremplaçable merci madame la
ministre avant de céder la parole à
monsieur gilles lurton
je veux le féliciter pour son élection à
la tête de saint malo lui dire tous nos
voeux de succès et lui dire aussi que
notre assemblée père un excellent
collègue mais je me console en me disant
que la bretagne y gagne vous avez la
parole chers collègues
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre alors que d'ici
quelques jours je quitterais des bancs
de cette assemblée pour assumer
pleinement mes fonctions de maire de
saint malo et de président de saint malo
agglomération
je souhaite témoigner de tout le monde
leur que j'ai ressenti à ce que j'ai ici
pendant huit années ici même dans cet
hémicycle j'ai pu participer pleinement
avec mes convictions à l'élaboration des
lois pendant presque deux quinquennats
oui j'ai la prétention de le faire
entendre publiquement le travail
accompli au cours de ses mandats avec
l'ensemble de mes collègues de la
commission des affaires sociales mais
également l'ensemble des groupes
composant cet hémicycle a contribué à
faire évoluer les lois et à répondre au
mieux à ce que je crois bon pour le
peuple français je les fais pour les
anciens combattants d'algérie je les
fais aussi pour les familles de notre
pays et tant d'autres sujets oui je suis
fier ici de représenter le peuple
français et de traduire ce qui l'attend
dans la loi je souhaite que le rôle
démocratique de notre assemblée
parlementaire puisse continuer d'être
respecté par le gouvernement dans
l'indépendance du pouvoir législatif
cette dernière l'occasion cette dernière
question est l'occasion de soulever une
erreur constitutionnel que je considère
comme majeure celle de la suppression du
mandat de député maire alors même que
ses deux mandats avait avait tout pour
que la légitimité du peuple français
puisse être reconnue puisse être reconnu
dans l'élaboration de la loi comment
comprendre que l'on puisse cumuler un
mandat de ministre avec un mandat de
nerfs et qu'un parlementaire ne le
pourrait pas monsieur le premier
ministre vous nous avez dit vous nous
avez dit vouloir être le premier
ministre des territoires
je formule le voeu que vous n'oubliez
pas les territoires de notre pays et
leur très grande diversité je viens là
territoire situé entre le mont saint
michel et saint briac sur mer en passant
par cancale dinard et saint-malo un
territoire de marin un territoire dans
lequel plus que jamais l'économie
maritime ont besoin de tout le soutien
du gouvernement la création d'un
ministère de la mer après trente années
d'absence constitue un encouragement
fort comment demain comptez vous
concilier votre politique avec la
diversité des besoins des territoires de
notre pays
merci chers collègues la parole est à
monsieur gabriel a tall secrétaire
d'état porte-parole du gouvernement
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
gilles lurton je veux au nom du
gouvernement vous c'est féliciter pour
votre élection vous souhaitez un beau
mandat à une action au service des
habitants de votre commune vous avez été
très engagé à l'assemblée nationale au
sein de la commission des affaires
sociales notamment sur les questions
d'emploi et de formation et à chacun ici
se souviendra de vos interventions en ce
sens finalement votre intervention est à
la fois très large et revêt assez peu de
questionnements mais vous parlez à la
fin de la prise en compte de la
diversité de nos territoires et je crois
que dans le mandat de ce gouvernement le
mandat qui a été confié par le président
de la république qui a été détaillé par
le premier ministre dans sa déclaration
de politique générale
il est extrêmement clair que nous nous
attacherons dans l'ensemble de notre
action du premier au dernier jour et du
matin au soir à tenir compte de cette
diversité de nos territoires dans une
logique évidemment de différenciation
mais aussi d'innovation de créativité de
chacun de nos territoires de mise en
valeur des atouts du territoire français
et des territoires français et vous avez
évoqué nk est un enjeu très important
qui est celui de l'économie maritime de
la croissance bleue ce gouvernement a
recréé un ministère plein et entier de
la mer c'est un progrès pour les
territoires comme celui que vous
représentez ce sont des opportunités et
des perspectives en termes de croissance
en termes de biodiversité extrêmement
forte pour notre pays le président avait
eu l'occasion d'exprimer une ambition
maritimes pour la france dans un
discours très importants à la fin de
l'année 2019
nous allons poursuivre sur cette voie
avec annick girardin et je suis sûr que
s'agissant du beau territoire que vous
représentez nous verrons très vite les
effets de cette politique jour merci
merci monsieur le ministre la parole
qu'à madame amérique le meur
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre délégué à
la ville
madame la ministre je commencerai mon
propos pas vous fassiez part vous
féliciter au nom de notre groupe pour
votre nomination et lui de trappes
vous connaissez à la fois les
difficultés le potentiel des quartiers
prioritaires
vous le savez la crise de lakovic 19 a
sans doute été là sans doute été plus
dur plus difficile pour les habitants
des quartiers relevant de la politique
de la ville ce sont nos deuxièmes et
troisièmes lignes mises en avant par le
président de la république
ces emplois pour lesquels le télétravail
est un mirage et qui ont pourtant permis
au pays de tenir ce sont ces familles
monoparentales avec parfois des horaires
variables qui ont eu des difficultés à
faire l'école à distance ou animer des
activités dans leur foyer ce sont ces
enfants pour qui les conditions pour
étudier bien se concentrer et à prendre
on était plus difficile qu'ailleurs
vivent confinés pendant deux mois dans
un appartement de taille réduite
ce sont ces jeunes qui ont eu dix
jardins et parcs pour échapper ne serait
ce qu'une heure au sentiment
d'enfermement créé par la crise
sanitaire
ce sont nos salariés apprentis encore
dans des communes où le taux de chômage
et 15 points au dessus de la moyenne
nationale qui ont perdu leur cdd ou leur
apprentissage
la crise de la covin 19 nous montre que
chaque pas en avant et fragile que la
situation des plus précaires peut
basculer d'un moment à un autre il
mérite notre solidarité pleine et
entière
nous devons pas nous ne devons laisser
personne au bord de la route
lors de son discours de tourcoing le
président de la république avait trouvé
les mots justes
il avait donné une feuille de route
porteuse d'espoir garantir l'effectivité
des droits et donner à chacun les armes
pour s'émanciper
ces objectifs ont été fragilisés
fragilisé par la crise sanitaire et
social aussi madame la ministre
pouvez vous nous détailler la politique
du gouvernement à court et long terme
afin de garantir le droit à l'éducation
au sport à la culture et à l'emploi dans
les quartiers politique de la ville
je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est à
madame nadia ministre délégué chargé de
la ville
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la députée
annaïg le meur je tiens sincèrement à
vous remercier pour votre question qui
rappelle la détresse de ces familles
pendant que confinement particulièrement
dans les territoires prioritaires de la
ville
et oui vous avez raison nous avons deux
priorités à l'issue de cette période
l'éducation et l'emploi et je vous ai je
peux vous assurer ici que le
gouvernement l'état jouera son rôle
pleinement dans ses enjeux d'abord pour
assurer la continuité pédagogique avec
un plan interministériel qui mobilise un
milieu 110 millions d'euros profite d'un
million trois cent mille jeunes
ce plan qui comprend les dispositifs
quartiers d'été écolo apprenantes vise à
accompagner les enfants dans la
découverte et l'apprentissage à la fois
au sein même de leur quartier et
également à travers des séjours partout
en france
j'ai pu constater au cours de mes
déplacements à hérouville saint clair à
clichy sous bois ou à montfermeil
l'énergie et la dynamique déployée et
elle c'est en cela que je veux soutenir
c'est la question de l'emploi ensuite
que vous soulignez le défi à relever est
immense dans les territoires déjà
fragilisé dans ce secteur c'est pourquoi
à la rentrée je mettrai en oeuvre un
programme ambitieux sur le modèle des
sites et éducative
l'enjeu est de faire travailler tous les
acteurs ensemble afin d'identifier et de
proposer des solutions d'emplois
tous ces dispositifs ne pourrait être
effectif ni efficace sans la
concertation et la participation des
élus locaux des acteurs éducatifs
associatifs et économiques
ils sont nos partenaires parce que
réussir ensemble c'est faire ensemble
cette expression est chère à mon
collègue julien de normandie et je
compte bien la poursuivre je salue donc
leur engagement tout comme je tiens à
vous remercier madame la députée pour
votre implication
je remercie également tous les
parlementaires engagés sur ce sujet et
je vous sais très nombreux vous pouvez
compter sur mon engagement et ma
détermination à poursuivre notre devoir
de ne laisser personne au bord du chemin
je vous remercie
merci madame la ministre
la parole est à monsieur thibault bazin
monsieur le premier ministre
désolé de tempérer votre flory sur le
plan européen un peu moins
d'autosatisfaction et un peu plus de
lucidité serait plus approprié alors
qu'il reste beaucoup de zones d'ombré à
dissiper combien cela coûtera aux
français
quels secteurs seront sacrifiés nous
sommes inquiets cela étant dit lors de
votre déclaration de politique générale
nous avons entendu une musique douce à
nos oreilles sur les territoires mots
que vous avez prononcé à 25 reprises
mais en même temps vous dites vous
inscrire dans la continuité vous
félicitant même du bilan des trois
dernières années
or le président macron et sa majorité
ont aggravé les fractures territoriales
en pénalisant les classes moyennes
candidate à l'accession à la propriété
avec sa majorité ils ont aussi
concentrés les dispositifs des aides à
la pierre sur les hypercentres de
métropole le dispositif de normandie en
marche soit disant depuis 18 mois est un
peu en panne
les opérations de revitalisation des
territoires tarde à se concrétiser dans
les bourgs centres
le programme petite ville de demain
apparaît déjà comme une conque
co-construction bien lourde la
rénovation énergétique semble
inaccessible à certains territoires des
intercommunalités rurales sont ainsi
privés de l'opération programmée
d'amélioration de l'habitat
monsieur le premier ministre vous vous
dites gaulliste social alors chiche pour
relancer l'activité du bâtiment et
générer des emplois locaux
allez vous mener une véritable politique
d'aménagement du territoire
chiche allez vous mener une véritable
politique familiale d'accession à la
propriété
merci madame emmanuelle wargon ministre
délégué chargé du rose du logement
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
thibeault bazin oui dans le plan de
relance avec 100 milliards
d'investissements nous mettrons 30
milliards d'investissements sur la
transition écologique et dans ces 30
transition écologique
nous soutiendrons fortement le secteur
de la construction
le secteur du bâtiment et notamment la
question de la rénovation énergétique
des bâtiments
cette question de la rénovation
énergétique elle est à la frontière
d'une politique du logement ambitieuse
et du mieux vivre chez soi d'une
politique de développement économique
d'une politique écologique et d'une
politique sociale
nous continuerons à soutenir fortement
le logement social
nous l'avons soutenu pendant la crise
avec un soutien spécifique d'action
logement et de la caisse des dépôts et
nous continuerons pour atteindre les
objectifs du logement social qui sont
les nôtres nous continuerons à soutenir
la construction neuve
bien sûr pendant la crise les chantiers
se sont arrêtés mais ils ont repris nous
avons d'ailleurs beaucoup travaillé avec
le secteur du bâtiment avec julien de
normandie pour aider ce secteur à
reprendre le plus vite possible les
chantiers nous savons que des
autorisations d'urbanisme ont pris du
temps que des délais ont été pris nous
allons les rattraper pour faire en sorte
qu'il n'y ait pas de trous dans la
construction neuve
enfin vous parler d'aménagement du
territoire c'est un bon mot qui a été
porté dans la période précédente que je
vais reprendre cet aménagement du
territoire souhaité par le premier
ministre qui consiste à aller à la
rencontre de tous les territoires à
répondre à leurs besoins tout en ayant
des objectifs écologiques de lutte
contre l'étalement urbain sera au coeur
de notre action avec les opérations
spécifiques d'aménagement avec les eaux
vertes et avec les ppa avec le programme
action coeur de ville chère à jacqueline
gourault avec le programme petite ville
de demain pour qu'on puisse partout en
france
vivre bien vivre mieux vous plaît
monsieur bazin allez-y c'est plus
sérieux
madame la ministre
votre réponse ne me rassure pas les
territoires restent l'angle mort de
votre politique soyons concrets il
faudrait dès demain rétablir totalement
le ptz dans les territoires détendu
rétablir la paix à l'accession améliorer
le pouvoir d'achat des familles en
relevant le quotient familial en
revalorisation revalorisant les
allocations familiales la prestation
d'accueil du jeune enfant
les territoires les familles des classes
moyennes restent les grandes oubliées de
ce quinquennat
elles attendent des actes de
l'efficacité et pas seulement des
paroles et en relançant ainsi l'activité
c'est autant d'emplois que vous pourriez
générés dans nos territoires
merci monsieur buzz
la parole est à mal à manier style merci
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre des
cultes
monsieur le ministre les images sont
sans appel les orgues du xviie siècle et
les vitraux 2498 ont définitivement
disparu
ci gît la cathédrale de nantes trois
départs de feu outre la menace
criminelle notre patrimoine notre
histoire nos chefs d'oeuvre n'ont jamais
été autant en danger
on n'efface pas notre histoire nous
sommes issus d'elle elle nous a façonné
que nous la précision ou pas nul ne sort
de nulle part
nul ne s'est fait tout seul en france on
recense plus de 500 églises directement
menacés et environ 5000 édifices
religieux en souffrance qui si rien
n'est fait risque de disparaître
cela fait plaisir à certains et c'est
bien cela qui doit nous alarmer dans un
pays qui revendique fièrement sa laïcité
le décompte officiel de place beauvau
pour 2019 est le suivant 1052 actes
antichrétiens 657 actes antisémites 154
actes anti musulmans
oui il y à un sujet en france
aujourd'hui celui de la protection de
notre laïcité et s'il faut combattre
l'antisémitisme
oui il faut combattre l'islamophobie
alors il faut aussi combattre tous ces
actes antichrétiens ce sont ce sont
trois actes antichrétiens par jour
monsieur le ministre
encore sur week-end en bretagne à l'île
d'ars l'abbaye de libourne et cette nuit
première abbaye fondée en france est
première en occident c'est un calvaire
ici une viergela un vol ailleurs une
destruction une soudure un incendie
trois par jour
les catholiques sont sympathiques parce
qu'à force il pourrait en avoir assez de
ces actes de vandalisme dont l'absence
d'entretien qui ne respectent ni notre
histoire qu'il faut bien acceptée comme
telle
ni leur religion je fais partie de ces
milliers de gens qui ne veulent plus
voir les cathédrales églises chapelles
abbaye lieux de culte cimetière calvaire
brûlé détruit profané soulier volet
abîmé vandalisés ou abandonnés lieux de
culte ils sont aussi ferment d'unité
expression d'identité et merveilles
d'art ma question est simple sa
tristesse indignés condamnés ne suffit
plus
qu'envisagez-vous de faire pour pro
tg ce qui fut notre histoire les lieux
de culte chrétiens je vous remercie
madame le député
permettez-moi tout de même de vous
rappelez vous avez interpellé monsieur
le ministre des cultes qui n'existe plus
depuis 1912
il existe un bureau des cultes placé
sous la responsabilité du ministre de
l'intérieur auquel je cède donc la
parole pour vous répondre
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la députée
le miso l'intérieur est certes de mise
la sécurité des français mais c'est
aussi le miz des libertés publiques
et parmi les libertés publiques
fondamentales il ya le fait de croire ou
de ne pas croire dans la république
française
le fait d'aller ou de ne pas aller
librement à son culte et le fait de
comprendre que son culte n'est jamais au
dessus des lois de la république
sur ce point monsieur le président
monsieur le député je suis sûr que tous
se rejoignent ici
mais madame vous allez poser une
question qui à la fois posé question des
actes antichrétiens anti catholique et
de manière générale anti religieux qu'il
faut évidemment condamné avec la
première force
je me permettrai de le distinguer de l'
incendie qui a eu lieu dans la
cathédrale de nantes je me suis rendu
avec monsieur le premier ministre
émana mise de la culture puisque à
l'heure où je vous parle rien n'indique
que ce soit un acte criminel
il est sous l'autorité du procureur de
la république de le considérer
il ya une enquête qui est ouverte la
garde à vue qui a été fait vous l'avez
vu la personne a été remise en liberté
il n'a pas été mis en examen et il se
pourrait que cet acte soit accidentel ce
qui ne retire en rien bien sûr l'émotion
exprimée padam la ministre de la culture
en revanche vous avez parfaitement une
raison de nombreux actes antireligieux
qu'il soit antisémite qu'il soit anti
musulmans anti islam ou anti chrétien
anti catholiques ont été malheureusement
perpétrés ces derniers temps rien que
pour le mois de janvier il ya eu
énormément d'actes anti chrétiens il y a
eu effectivement des statuettes de la
vierge marie qui ont été renversées et
brisées dans les pyrénées-atlantiques
dans huit églises à mons atteignant une
crèche qui a été renversé et jésus qui
étaient décapités de nombreux tags à
l'église du mans dans le calvados des
pèlerins qui ont été attaqués
oui vous avez raison la députée il ya
des actes antichrétiens il ya des actes
anti religieux et dès ma prise de
fonction j'ai contacté le président de
la conférence des évêques de france
les représentants du culte musulman les
représentants du culte juif pour leur
dire évidemment toute la protection de
la nation et je me rendrai dimanche à
saint-etienne du rouvray pour assister
évidemment à la messe anniversaire de ce
triste assassinat par un terroriste
islamiste du prêtre hamel merci beaucoup
merci monsieur le ministre la parole à
monsieur jean paul dufrègne monsieur le
président madame la ministre chargée de
la cohésion des territoires les zones de
revitalisation rurale concerne
aujourd'hui 13 1902 communes
représentant un peu plus de six millions
d'habitants
pour rappel le classement en zrr ouvre
droit à des exonérations fiscales
temporaires pour les entreprises en cas
de création ou de reprise d'activité et
des exonérations de cotisations sociales
pour les organismes d'intérêt général
comme des associations des ehpad des
structures des dallas personnes entre
autres c'est un critère souvent
déterminant pour le choix d'une
implantation qu'elles soient
commerciales artisanales ou de services
comme la santé par exemple
ce dispositif permet donc d'accompagner
le développement d'activités notamment
de très petites entreprises dans des
zones économiquement fragiles comme dans
de nombreuses communes de mon
département de l'allier
comme tout dispositif il n'est sans
doute pas parfait et plusieurs rapports
parfois contradictoires se sont évertués
soit a montré sa pertinence
soit en montré ses limites un certain
nombre de communes devait en sortir en
juin 2020 date repoussée en décembre
d'autres devaient y rentrer j'ai souvent
entendu dans cette enceinte
notamment en ce qui concerne la
fiscalité que les entreprises
confrontées à des choix devait le faire
en toute connaissance de cause dans un
contexte pour le moins troublée où
l'activité économique est percutée de
plein fouet par les conséquences de la
crise du coc vide
le moment est sans doute mal choisi pour
remettre en cause des dispositifs qui
profite à des territoires souvent à la
peine est par ailleurs souvent
maltraités notamment en termes de
présence de service public
ma question madame la ministre est donc
très simple les députés communistes et
gdr souhaite connaître vos intentions en
ce qui concerne les zones de revers de
revitalisation rurale à la fois pour les
communes concernées mais aussi sur
l'évolution éventuelle du dispositif
merci chers collègues la parole est à
madame jacqueline gourault ministre de
la cohésion de territoire des relations
et des collectivités territoriales
merci et monsieur jean paul dufrègne
pour votre question monsieur le député
vous m'interrogez sur l'évolution des
zones de revitalisation rurale zrr qui
comme vous l'avez rappelé ouvre des
droits à des exonérations fiscales et
sociales
effectivement constatant le caractère
complexe sédimenter également peut-être
insuffisamment ciblées de notre
géographie prioritaire
il a été conclu dès l'automne dernier
dans le cadre de l'agenda rural qu'il
était nécessaire de le réformer avec
l'accord et la demande des élus ruraux
les zones de revitalisation rurale
constitue vous l'avez dit vous allez
donner des chiffres
moi je vais dire un pourcentage chez la
moitié des communes françaises
une mission a donc été chargé au mois de
janvier afin d'évaluer l'efficacité des
dispositifs zone et est de proposer des
scénarios d'évolution
c'est chose faite le rapport vient de
m'être remis alors naturellement des
pistes sont proposées certaines recouvre
d'ailleurs des propositions faites par
les rapports parlementaires aussi bien
ici qu'au sénat qui ont été faits et
naturellement nous devons engager des
concertations avec les élus nationaux et
locaux pour déterminer la stratégie à
adopter
j'ai insisté sur trois points premier
point je veux qu'il y ait un temps
suffisamment suffisant pardon qui soit
accordée aux discussions pour se dit
positif qui est très important pour les
territoires ruraux
deuxièmement le gouvernement a
parfaitement l'intérêt d'un tel
dispositif pour le développement des
territoires
et bien évidemment il n'y aura pas de
rupture
il y aura une continuité et
troisièmement tout nouvel toute nouvelle
proposition tout nouveau dispositif ne
pourra permettre qu'un rang soutien
renforcé aux territoires les plus
vulnérables je vous remercie
merci madame le ministre la parole est à
madame audrey du ve jubeir merci
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les ministres chers collègues
cette question s'adresse à madame la
ministre brigitte bourguignon délégué à
l'autonomie
depuis le rapport laroque en 1962 la
question du vieillissement a traversé de
nombreux gouvernements de nombreux
parlements les réponses elles se sont
construites sur de fortes attentes
citoyennes souvent au lendemain de
crises successives je pense notamment à
la crise de la canicule en 2003 qui a
abouti à la création de la cia nsa ou
plus récemment bien évidemment la crise
du coc vide 2020 qui m'amène aujourd'hui
à poser à nouveau ce sujet ici sur ces
bancs chaque député
quelle que soit sa couleur politique ne
peut que reconnaître le défi que nous
devons tous relever celui de la
transition de l'âge dans notre société
le virage démographique de la france et
les besoins de financement accru pour le
soutien l'autonomie démontre l'urgence
politique
le parlement va ancrer dans la loi la
cinquième branche autonomie et nous
saluons cette avancée est cette volonté
réelle
cependant les mesures politiques portées
par le gouvernement pour la longévité
doivent être rapide efficace et visible
nous avons matière et nous connaissons
dorénavant les priorités au travers de
différents rapports de nombreux rapports
tels que celui de dominique libault de
myriam el khomri ou encore du mien remis
en décembre dernier et illustrée
récemment pendant la crise du coc vite
par jérôme guedj le ségur de la santé
portée par le ministre olivier ferrand
reconnaît et valorise les soignant des
établissements de santé en ehpad
seulement 95 % des personnes âgées sont
à la maison
et ces personnes elle souhaitait rester
le plus longtemps possible
accompagnés de leur entourage de leurs
proches ou encore de leurs aides à
domicile qui parfois sont le seul et
unique lien social alors madame la
ministre
quelle est votre feuille de route pour
permettre aux personnes âgées de
vieillir selon leur choix et libertés
individuelles pour que cela soit
respectée qu'allez vous déployez pour
que nous puissions enfin passer à
l'action et que 2020 ne soit pas vain
merci madame brigitte bourguignon lui
sont déléguées l'autonomie merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la députée
audrey du feu gilbert vous le savez vous
y avez contribué madame la députée dans
quelques jours le parlement va ouvrir la
voie à la création d'un nouveau risque
la cinquième branche de la sécurité
sociale
ce risque et les modalités de fond que
de financement doivent désormais faire
l'objet d'une concertation avec les
parties prenantes et avec les
parlementaires
vous le savez aussi il ya d'autres
travaux parlementaires sur la feuille de
route dont vous me parlez il ya eu aussi
ce sont les ehpad conduit par monique
iborra et caroline fiat que je
souhaitais salué les fondations étaient
indispensables mais il faut désormais
penser à la maison elle-même
c'est-à-dire la politique publique que
nous voulons pour nos aînés avec et au
plus près des territoires
l'ambition du gouvernement est simple
elle se veut forte préserver le libre
choix et surtout la dignité de nos
compatriotes âgées en perte d'autonomie
les grandes priorités du chantier que je
vais mener ces prochains mois avec
olivier ferrand et sous l'autorité du
premier ministre
tout d'abord une ambition forte pour
l'accompagnement et le soin à domicile
j'y suis particulièrement sensible
deuxièmement un changement de modèle
pour les ehpad pour en faire de vrais
lieux de vie adaptés aux besoins les
plus lourds
troisièmement un soutien résolu au
développement d'une troisième voie les
solutions d'habitat partagé j'y
travaillerai avec ma collègue chargé du
logement de petites unités de vie à
taille humaine dotée d'un accompagnement
mutualiser et enfin et ensuite une
ambition pour tous les métiers du grand
âge qui doivent devenir les fers de
lance de la politique du prendre soin je
vous fais attention
tâchez au sujet j'ajouterai
l'affirmation de la pleine citoyenneté
de la personne âgée dans notre société
et sa place et son rôle dans la vie de
la cité
de premières mesures seront présentées
dans le plfss 2021 pour agir
concrètement rapidement et répondre aux
besoins du secteur
soyez assurés que nous avons devant nous
de nombreux rendez vous sur le grand âge
et nous avons besoin de la mobilisation
de toutes et tous merci merci madame la
ministre la pole de monsieur loïc
prud'hommes merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre de l'agriculture
les citoyens et citoyennes demande la
transition de notre agriculture pour
produire des aliments sains pour
respecter la santé des paysans et des
consommateurs l'urgence climatique
demande la transition vers
l'agroécologie sobre en intrants en
énergie et économes en eau la crise du
coc vide demande la relocalisation des
productions et l'atteinte rapide de
l'autonomie alimentaire le président
macron nous avaient annoncé qu'ils
obtiendraient de l'europe une politique
agricole renforcée pour toutes ces
raisons essentielles nous venons de
prendre acte du résultat des
négociations budgétaires achevé cette
nuit et ce n'est pas glorieux
le budget de la politique agricole
commune et ratiboiser de 46 milliards
d'euros mais la pac
ce n'est pas qu'un tiroir caisse c'est
avant tout une politique et celle des
six ans à venir c'est la même qu'avant
empire le premier pilier qui comprend
les aides directes perd 27 milliards
d'euros soit une baisse de 10%
mais le plus grave c'est la chute
vertigineuse du budget dédié à
l'agriculture biologique et à toutes les
pratiques vertueuses pour notre
environnement et notre alimentation
le fameux deuxième pilier ce sont dix
neuf milliards d'euros qui partent en
fumée soit une baisse historique pour
reprendre le qualificatif cher au
président une baisse historique de 20%
c'est une défaite en rase campagne au
sens littéral du terme
votre prédécesseur mme avaient refusé en
février dernier un débat parlementaire
sur le plan stratégique national pour
l'agriculture demandées par l'union
européenne
on comprend maintenant pourquoi
deux stratégies vous n'en avez pas même
sur les traités de libre échange vous
capitulé en coulisses monsieur le
ministre
quand allez vous enfin tracer un avenir
pour nos agriculteurs et les défendre
contre le dumping social et
environnemental d'une europe des
égoïstes sponsorisé par bailleur
monsanto pulvérisateur de cancer ou
encore par amazon fossoyeur de nos zones
humides et du foncier agricole
merci chers collègues la parole est à
monsieur julien de normandie ministre de
l'agriculture et de l'alimentation
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
loïc prud'hommes la réalité c'est que
vous aimez pas l'europe
la réalité c'est que vous ne
reconnaissez jamais ce que l'europe peut
nous apporter
jamais en rien et la réalité monsieur le
député c'est que vous préférez dire des
contrevérités pour mieux critiquer
l'europe et ça c'est scandaleux parce
que monsieur le député prud'hommes vous
êtes comme moi vous êtes comme moi un
spécialiste des questions agricoles je
connais votre parcours vous êtes un
spécialiste des questions agricoles et
vous c'est très vous savez très bien
monsieur le député prud'hommes que
lorsqu'on calcule la pac
comment on calcule la pac on calcule la
pac d'abord en euros courants et vous le
savez très bien parce que les euros
courants c'est ce que les agriculteurs
ils perçoivent et en euros courants
la proposition obtenu cette nuit c'est
que le budget non seulement a été
stabilisé et il est même en augmentation
sur le premier et le deuxième qui met le
deuxième point monsieur prudhomme
c'est que l'honnêteté par rapport aux
tweets que vous avez fait cet après midi
vous aurez peut-être obligé à prendre en
compte dans vos calculs ne serait-ce que
le plan de relance parce que le plan de
relance il vient abonder un des deux
piliers de la pac et vous le savez très
bien monsieur député prud'hommes
et vous savez monsieur le député en 1950
robert schuman disait que pour faire
l'europe
il faut que chacun soit animé de ce
qu'il a très bien qualifier un effort
créateurs parce que oui l'europe
c'est un effort c'est beaucoup plus
facile de les détruire que de la
construire
parce que oui pour faire l'europe il
faut avoir un esprit
créatif c'est ce que les chefs de
gouvernement ont montré cette nuit avec
cet accord historique que cet accord que
cette nuit puissent en vous faire naître
cet effort créateurs j'en serai ravi
merci monsieur le ministre la balle est
à monsieur nicolas turquois merci
monsieur le président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à madame
la ministre chargé de l'industrie
le gouvernement mis en place
d'importants plans sectoriels pour
soutenir l'activité
8 milliards pour l'automobile 15
milliards pour l'aéronautique
ils sont essentiels pour nos champions
nationaux
mais je m'interroge sur la capacité de
ses plans à faire ruisseler ses moyens
colossaux vers les sous traitants dans
ma circonscription
ce sont les fonderies du poitou pour
l'automobile emeka fille pour
l'aéronautique qui sont en grande
difficulté car le retour des chefs
d'entreprises de sous-traitance est
quasi unanime dans l'aéronautique par
exemple ce sont les pratiques suivantes
qui sont à l'oeuvre blocage des
livraisons pour éviter d'avoir à les
régler pression démesurée sur les prix
marges arrières retards de paiement
la liste est longue et malheureusement
la seule charge en vigueur pour lutter
contre ces pratiques a manifestement ou
été oublié il est temps pour l'état que
les commandes publiques supplémentaires
sa compagne effectivement d'une sous
traitance française et ce dans des
conditions respectables
deuxième difficulté à laquelle ces
entreprises sont confrontées
la capitalisation de ces pme le fond
aéronautique qui se met en place et
abondé à 50% par les big for thales
safran airbus dassault mais au vu de la
très faible valorisation actuelle des
pme de l'aéronautique faire rentrer ce
fonds c'est faire rentrer le loup dans
la bergerie des collectivités je pense
par exemple à la région nouvelle
aquitaine sont prêtes à participer
massivement pour garantir dans le temps
long un financement stable sent
dépossédé les entrepreneurs mais c'est
semble-t-il la bpi qui fremm ses
initiatives en limitant à 50 % la part
de capitaux publics là où l'europe
elle-même autorise 70 % comme le
répètent à l'envi monsieur le premier
ministre la solution peut là aussi venir
des territoires madame la ministre que
ce soit sur le comportement inacceptable
de certains donneurs d'ordre ou le
financement de long
des entreprises pourriez vous nous
donner des éclaircissements pour que
demain nous ayons des pme et des nti
nombreux efforts pour produire et
innover je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole à madame
agnès pannier ministre délégué à
l'industrie
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
turquois votre inquiétude est légitime
notamment sur les dossiers que vous
mentionnez sur fonderie du poitou vous
savez comme moi que c'est un sujet qui
vient de loin et qui a certes connu des
difficultés supplémentaires avec locaux
vides mais qui malheureusement était
d'ores et déjà établi nous avons eu lieu
de nous battre pour ce volet dossier
l'année dernière et nous allons
continuer à nous battre
de manière plus générale sur les
filières aéronautiques et automobiles
je veux d'abord dire que le gouvernement
a pris ses responsabilités il a pris ses
responsabilités avec une seule boussole
monsieur le ministre de l'économie des
finances et de la relance a bien dit
c'est l'emploi c'est l'emploi c'est le
capital humain c'est la préservation des
compétences sur le territoire et c'est
ça qui justifie l'ensemble des mesures
que nous avons prises des mesures
d'ailleurs qui ne sont pas uniquement
orientée vers les grands groupes
c'est le cas du soutien à l'aéronautique
et à des programmes de développement
puisque une partie de thé y ait de pme
en bénéficient c'est le cas du fonds
diversification qui existant pour
l'aéronautique que pour l'automobile et
qui est spécifiquement dédié à des pme
et à des étés y est c'est le cas des
dispositifs d'accompagnement en fonds
propres que vous avez mentionné
je veux vous rassurer sur ces
dispositifs d'accompagnement en fonds
propres d'abord parce que le fond
aéronautique que nous mettons en place
et qui a existé il ya une dizaine
d'années il se trouve que j'étais à la
manoeuvre à ce moment là au fonds
stratégique d'investissement prend ses
décisions et prendra ses décisions de
manière autonome et dans l'objectif de
développer les entreprises nous l'avions
fait pour d'air et ça s'était très bien
passé nous l'avions fait pour mecachrome
et ça s'était très bien passé il ya dix
ans nous continuerons à agir comme ça et
puis surtout ça n'interdit pas
évidemment en région d'intervenir nous
allons conforter au contraire les fonds
régionaux des régions pour intervenir
dans ces capitaux enfin s'agissant des
donneurs d'ordre et sous traitance nous
serons
ce très mauvais bilan sur les délais de
paiement sur la visibilité sur les
cadences et sur l'attitude générale des
donneurs d'ordres pour qu'il accompagne
en solidarité l'ensemble de la sous
traitance simonow le ministre la séance
des questions au gouvernement et
terminer la séance suspendue